ओके
गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग
एवरीबॉडी आई थिंक आई एम लाइव नाउ सो प्लीज
लेट मी नो गाइस इफ आई एम ऑडिबल एंड विज़िबल
क्लियरली हेलो टू एवरीवन गुड इवनिंग गुड
इवनिंग नमस्ते सभी को एक बार मुझे जल्दी
से सभी लोग बता दीजिए इफ आई एम ऑडिबल
एक बार मुझे जल्दी से बता दीजिए सभी लोग
इफ आई एम इफ आई एम ऑडिबल एंड विजिबल
सही से आप मुझे मुझे देख देख पा रहे हैं,
सुन पा रहे हैं। नमस्ते गुड इवनिंग
एवरीबॉडी। प्लीज लेट मी नो सभी लोग।
नमस्ते नमस्ते। भाई नमस्ते सभी को एक बार
बता दीजिए जल्दी से।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके ओके तो एक बार सभी को आ जाने देते
हैं। फटाफट सभी को ज्वाइन करने देते हैं।
देन वी विल बी स्टार्टिंग।
ऑल क्लियर है। गुड। चलिए आज की भी सेशन
बहुत शानदार होने वाली है। मजेदार होने
वाली है। मजा आएगा आप सभी को। बस बने रहिए
सेशन में। मजे कीजिए सेशन में। यू विल लव
द सेशन। बिकॉज़ आज का सेशन भी एक ऐसे
इंपॉर्टेंट टॉपिक पे है जो आपके लिए काफी
इंपॉर्टेंट है। बीइंग एज एन एसओसी एल वन
या एसोसिए एनालिस्ट की तरह या जूनियर
सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट की तरह आपके लिए
बहुत-बहुत ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है। बस वो
मैं आपको बताऊंगा। बट उसके पहले
मैं [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] यहां पे
आपको एक चीज नोट करके लिख के यहां पे सभी
को बताना चाहता हूं ताकि सबको दिखे।
नेक्स्ट एसओसी क्लास विल हैपन
ओनली यह ताकि सबको पता रहे आफ्टर 200 प्लस
यूनिक
और नॉन रिपीटेड कमेंट्स।
रिपीटेड कमेंट्स
वोंट काउंट। ठीक है? बस ये चीज अ मैंने
आपको बता दिया। ये चीज मैं यहां पे टाइप
यहां पे सामने रख के रख रहा हूं आपके लिए
ताकि सभी को समझ आए, पता चले कि भैया
एग्जैक्टली ये एक कंडीशन होती है जो मैंने
आप सबके लिए रखी है। एंड दिस इज़ नॉट अ बिग
डील। दिस इज़ नॉट अ बिग कंडीशन कि हर एसओसी
क्लास के ऊपर अगर 200 से भी ज्यादा
कमेंट्स आप कर देते हैं जो पहले 250 मैंने
रखा था एक अह थ्रेशहोल्ड उसको रिड्यूस
किया आपके लिए ताकि और क्लासेस जल्दी ला
सकूं मैं 200 से ऊपर यूनिक और नॉन रिपीटेड
कमेंट्स ऐसा नहीं कि एक ही बंदा 10 कमेंट
कर रहा है क्योंकि हम जब फ़्टर करते हैं तो
पता चलता है एक कमेंट्स एक ही आईडी से या
एक ही बंदे ने मल्टीपल आईडी से मल्टीपल
कमेंट्स कर दिए तो दिस इज़ नॉट फेयर इनफ
राइट सो 200 प्लस यूनिक कमेंट्स आपको करने
हैं इसका [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] रीज़न
बहुत सिंपल सिंपल सा है। आपको बताने की
जरूरत नहीं है। कुछ कारण से यह चीजें मैं
कर रहा हूं ताकि आपकी जो है इंगेजमेंट बनी
रहे इस चीज के अंदर में। एटलीस्ट आप कमेंट
के बहाने खोलें एंड देखें एंड चीजों को
करें। तो ये कमेंट करना आपका इंपॉर्टेंट
है। एंड ये आपको जो है थ्रेशहोल्ड लाना
पड़ेगा। एंड नेक्स्ट क्लास उसके बाद हो
जाएगी। जैसे अभी आपने 200 कमेंट्स कर दिए।
हालांकि 200 कमेंट्स दो दिन पहले ही हो
चुके थे। बट वो फर्जी 200 कमेंट्स थे।
जैसे ही रियल 200 कमेंट्स हुए। मैं आपके
लिए आज सेशन लेकर आ चुका हूं। ठीक है? आई
होप कि आप सभी इसको फॉलो करेंगे। तो आज की
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
अरे चार कमेंट्स नहीं करने ना करने चार
कमेंट्स आप चीजों को समझते नहीं आप यही तो
मैं बोलने की कोशिश कर रहा हूं। यू डोंट
हैव टू डू द फोर कमेंट्स। राइट? एक ही
बंदे के पास से फोर कमेंट नहीं। यूनिक
बंदे आने चाहिए। राइट?
चलिए [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
तो आज के टॉपिक पे आते हैं। उसके पहले एक
इंपॉर्टेंट चीज बता देता हूं। आप किसी भी
डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी का जब YouTube चैनल ओपन
करेंगे, किसी भी लाइव सेक्शन में एसओसी
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] के कोई सी भी
क्लास को ओपन करेंगे तो इसके डिस्क्रिप्शन
में आपको चले जाना है। ठीक है? यहां
डिस्क्रिप्शन में दो लिंक्स मिलेंगे। एक
WhatsApp ग्रुप का लिंक मिलेगा, एक
WhatsApp हमारे चैनल का लिंक मिलेगा। इस
दोनों को सबसे पहले ओपन कर लीजिएगा दो टैब
में। पहला ग्रुप होगा एसओसी एनालिस्ट का
ग्रुप जो कि स्पेशली इस एसओसी बैच एंड इस
एसओसी क्लासेस के लिए बनी है। एंड इस
एसओसी के इन ग्रुप्स में लगभग लगभग यू विल
नॉट बिलीव कि 4000 से भी ज्यादा
एंथूजियास्ट्स हैं एसओसी के जो इस बैच इस
ट्रेनिंग के साथ जुड़े हैं और इस ग्रुप
में जुड़े हुए हैं। आपको यह ग्रुप जॉइन कर
लेना है क्योंकि जितने भी रिसोर्सेज,
नोट्स या जो भी चीज़ें आपको मिलेंगी इस
ट्रेनिंग के रिगार्डिंग वह सबसे पहले इसी
ग्रुप में मिलने वाली हैं। और इसी ग्रुप
में ओनली आने वाले जो भी अपडेट्स होंगी
चाहे वो रिसोर्सेज के रिगार्डिंग हो, चाहे
सर्टिफिकेशन के रिगार्डिंग हो, चाहे वो
एग्जाम, मॉक इंटरव्यूज या किसी भी तरीके
से या जॉब रिकमेंडेशन इस ट्रेनिंग को खत्म
होने के बाद सब चीजें इसी ग्रुप में आने
वाली है। तो इसको जरूर जॉइ कीजिएगा। दूसरी
चीज है ये WhatsApp चैनल है। आपको जितनी
अपडेट्स रिलेटेड चीजें होती है ना वो सबसे
पहले हम WhatsApp चैनल पे भेजते हैं। चाहे
वो ओवरऑल मैं सारी अपडेट्स की बात करूं
इंक्लूडिंग एसओसी और बाकी सारी चीजें। तो
इसको फॉलो जरूर कर लीजिएगा। ठीक है? यहां
पे भी 11,000 से ज्यादा लर्नर्स ने हमें
फॉलो करके रखा है। एंड हमारे साथ जुड़े
फॉर डिफरेंट काइंड ऑफ़ अपडेट्स। यह Lindin
पेज है। यह मेरी Lindin पेज प्रोफाइल है।
आप इस पे चाहे तो मुझसे कनेक्ट हो सकते
हैं एंड मुझे फॉलो कर सकते हैं। इसी पे आप
डिफ्रॉनिक्स सर्च कर देंगे तो आपको
डिफ्रॉनिक साइबर सिक्योरिटी हमारी जो
कंपनी का Lindin पेज है आपको वो सिंपली
मिल जाता है। एंड आप उसको भी फॉलो कर
लीजिएगा फॉलो करके। एंड यहां पे हमारी
कंपनी से कंपनी के रिगार्डिंग जो भी
अपडेट्स जो भी आपको पोस्ट्स या जो भी आपको
न्यूज़ वगैरह होंगी वह सब आपको मिल जाएंगी।
यहां पे भी लगभग 21,000 लोग हमारे साथ
जुड़े हुए हैं। तो, आप इसको फॉलो कर
लीजिएगा Lindin पे। यह हमारा एक्स पेज है
यानी कि Twitter पेज है जो कि डिफ़ॉन एकडमी
हैंडल के साथ आता है। यहां पे फॉलो कर
लीजिएगा। यहां पे भी आपको अलग-अलग चीजें
मिलने वाली है। यह हमारा Instagram पेज है
डिफ़ॉन एकडमी का। यहां आपको इनेशनल जो है
कंटेंट्स मिल जाते हैं रील्स के फॉर्म में
मोस्टली। ये हमारी वेबसाइट है। वेबसाइट पे
आके आप विजिट करके इस वेबसाइट विजिट कर
सकते हैं। एकडमी पे जाके हमारे
डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट कोर्सेज को एक्सप्लोर कर
सकते हैं। परचेस एनरोल कर सकते हैं। एंड
इस नंबर पे हमसे किसी भी तरह की क्वेरीज
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] आप कर सकते हैं।
तो सारी चीजें क्लियर आउट हो चुकी हैं। आई
होप अब चलिए हम अपने मेन टॉपिक पे आ जाते
हैं। पहले अब आज की जो टॉपिक है वो
इंटरेस्टिंग है क्योंकि नेटवर्किंग पार्ट
जो है वह अपने आप में होल नेटवर्किंग
पार्ट ही काफी इंटरेस्टिंग है। एंड उसमें
हमने जो लास्ट सेशन में करा था वो उससे और
ज्यादा एक स्टेप फॉरवर्ड हम आगे जा रहे
हैं। एंड हम आज जो है वो करने वाले हैं
प्रोटोकॉल्स एंड पोर्ट्स के बारे में
डिस्कशन। अब ये प्रोटोकॉल्स एंड पोर्ट्स
के बारे में डिस्कशन करेंगे। इनको समझेंगे
क्योंकि यह बहुत बड़ा रोल प्ले करते हैं।
मेजर रोल प्ले करते हैं फॉर अ एसओसी एल1
एंड आप अगर एसओसी एल1 बन रहे हैं, आप इसी
फील्ड में करियर बना रहे हैं, जॉब के लिए
जा रहे हैं तो आपको इन टॉपिक्स की नॉलेज
बिल्कुल होनी चाहिए। मैंडेटरीली होनी
चाहिए। इसमें कोई ऑप्शन नहीं है कि वेदर
यू शुड बी अह हैविंग द नॉलेज ऑफ़ दीज़ काइंड
ऑफ़ टॉपिक्स ऑ नॉट। आपके पास ऑप्शन नहीं है
कि मुझे ये टॉपिक्स सीखनी चाहिए कि नहीं,
पढ़नी चाहिए कि नहीं। आपके पास ये ये आपके
लिए मैंडेटरी है। दिस इज़ क्वाइट मैंडेटरी
फॉर यू टू गो थ्रू दीज़ टॉपिक्स एंड टू
लर्न टू अंडरस्टैंड दीज़ टॉपिक्स। तो रियल
स्किल्स वो उन्हीं को कहते हैं जब आप किसी
एक टॉपिक को ट्रूली समझ जाते हो। दिमाग
में फिट कर लेते हो एंड प्रॉपर्ली उसके
कांसेप्ट को समझ जाते हो। देन आप जब आगे
चल के किसी भी तरह का डेमोंस्ट्रेशन
करेंगे। हम प्रैक्टिकल्स करेंगे। जब हम
एसओसी के प्रैक्टिकल पार्ट पे आएंगे तो
वहां पे फिर आपको मजा आएगा। क्योंकि आपकी
थ्योरी कंप्लीट है, कांसेप्ट कंप्लीट है।
अब जब प्रैक्टिकल चीजें जब चीजें आपके
सामने हो रही होंगी तो आपको पता चलेगा
अच्छा ये वो वाली चीज हुई थी जो हमने
कांसेप्ट पढ़ा था। वही चीज यहां पे हम
अप्लाई कर रहे हैं। तो फिर मजा आने वाला
है। सो एवरीवन रेडी एक बार मुझे बता
दीजिए। सभी लोग एक बार बता दीजिए। एवरीवन
रेडी प्लीज लेट मी नो। फास्ट
हां। [गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][खांसने की आवाज़]
चलिए। सो ऑलमोस्ट सभी लोग रेडी हैं। तो
नाउ वी विल बी स्टार्टिंग इट। राइट?
रेडी?
सर, मैं एक एसओसी एनालिस्ट का टूल
अह बना रहा हूं। सब काम एक ही क्लिक में
कर देगा मॉनिटरिंग नेटवर्क अलर्ट। बहुत
अच्छी बात है। बहुत बढ़िया। ऑल द बेस्ट।
आई होप कि यू गेट सक्सेस एट दैट। राइट?
सो, लेट्स स्टार्ट गाइज़। और हां, लेट हो
गया, कोई बात नहीं, कोई बात नहीं, लेट हो
गया कोई बात नहीं है। आ तो गए एटलीस्ट
थोड़ी लेट हो गए तो चलेगा बट आ तो गए हैं।
दैट मैटर्स एक्चुअली। ओके?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] हां जी।
सबसे पहले हम प्रोटोकॉल्स के बारे में
जानेंगे। देन हम पोर्ट्स के बारे में
जानेंगे। एंड एक-एक चीज समझिएगा थोड़ा।
सबसे पहले हम क्या होते हैं वेब
प्रोटोकॉल्स? प्रोटोकॉल्स को हम वेब
प्रोटोकॉल्स भी बोलते हैं। एंड जनरली कई
लोग एचटीटीपी प्रोटोकॉल्स भी बोल देते
हैं। बट इट्स अ इट्स
इट्स अ गुड टू से इट एज वेब प्रोटोकॉल्स
या सिंपली प्रोटोकॉल्स या नेटवर्क
प्रोटोकॉल्स आल्सो यू कैन से। राइट? सो अ
वेब प्रोटोकॉल इज़ सिंपली अ सेट ऑफ़ रूल्स।
सिंपल सा फंडा है। प्रोटोकॉल का मतलब होता
है रूल। ये दिमाग में आप बिठा लीजिए।
प्रोटोकॉल का मतलब होता है एक तरीका, एक
अप्रोच, एक वे। ठीक है? एक रास्ता, एक ऐसा
अप्रोच, एक ऐसा वे जिसके थ्रू कोई चीज हम
कर पा रहे हैं। दैट इज प्रोटोकॉल। तो आपने
सुना होगा कि पीएम का पीएम का एक
प्रोटोकॉल होता है। सीएम का एक प्रोटोकॉल
होता है। राइट? तो ये जो प्रोटोकॉल क्या
होता है? जैसे पीएम का एक प्रोटोकॉल होता
है फॉर सिक्योरिटी रीज़ंस। सीएम का एक
प्रोटोकॉल होता है फॉर सिक्योरिटी रीज़ंस।
तो सिक्योरिटी रीजंस की वजह से बट
प्रोटोकॉल क्या है? एक तरीका होता है कि
अब जैसे आप पीएम के प्रोटोकॉल पे समझे तो
पीएम कैसे भी कुछ भी नहीं कर सकते। जैसे
आपने न्यूज़ में सुना होगा कि पीएम ने
प्रोटोकॉल को तोड़ के
एक फॉरेन कंट्री के पीएम को या जो
प्रेसिडेंट है उसको रिसीव किया। तो
प्रोटोकॉल को तोड़ के मतलब एक सेट ऑफ
रूल्स है एक तरीका है जिसको उनको फॉलो
करना है। क्योंकि ही इज़ नॉट अ इंडिविजुअल
पर्सन एनीमोर एज़ सून ऐज़ ही बिकम द पीएम।
ही बिकम अ पर्सन हु इज रिप्रेजेंटिंग अ
नेशन ही इज़ द प्राइम मिनिस्टर। तो प्राइम
मिनिस्टर का एक प्रोटोकॉल होता है। अब उस
प्रोटोकॉल को फॉलो करना ही पड़ता है। हां
कभी-कभी तोड़ दिया क्योंकि उन्हीं के ऊपर
प्रोटोकॉल है तो वो अलग बात है। दैट दैट
इज़ अनदर थिंग। बट कंप्यूटर अ नेटवर्किंग
के केस में यहां पे जो पूरी इंटरनेट काम
करती है वो एक प्रोटोकॉल पे काम करती है।
वेब प्रोटोकॉल कहते हैं। अब वेब प्रोटोकॉल
इज़ अ सेट ऑफ़ रूल्स। ये सेट ऑफ रूल्स है
दैट डिफाइन हाउ डेटा इज सेंट एंड रिसीव्ड
ओवर अ नेटवर्क। इंटरनेट पे डेटा कैसे सेंड
किया जाता है और कैसे रिसीव किया जाएगा
इसको
शोकेस करती है क्या? वेब प्रोटोकॉल। इसी
के लिए एक सेट ऑफ रूल्स बनाया गया जिसको
हम वेब प्रोटोकॉल कहते हैं। बस इसी को
डिफाइन करती है कि भैया इंटरनेट पे डेटा
कैसे भेजा जाए और कैसे रिसीव किया जाए।
दैट्स इट। बहुत सिंपल सा इसका डेफिनेशन
है। एज [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] अ ह्यूमन
आप किसी से कैसे इंटरेक्ट करते हो? किसी
से भी बात करनी हो, इंटरेक्ट करनी हो तो
आपका एक ही प्रोटोकॉल है। वो है लैंग्वेज
के थ्रू। बिना लैंग्वेज के आप इंटरेक्ट
नहीं कर सकते। आपका लैंग्वेज कुछ भी हो
सकता है, हिंदी हो सकता है, उर्दू हो सकता
है, मराठी हो सकता है, इंग्लिश हो सकती
है। राइट? चाइनीज़ हो सकता है, जैपनीज़ हो
सकता है, अमेरिकन इंग्लिश हो सकती है।
व्हाटएवर। तो वो एक प्रोटोकॉल है जिसके
थ्रू आप इंटरेक्ट कर रहे हो। अब मान लो कि
आप चाइना में जा रहे हो। अब सामने वाले को
इंग्लिश नहीं आती। चाइनीज़ आपको तो आनी
चाहिए अगर आपको इंटैक्ट करना है तो। दैट
व्हाट इज कॉल्ड प्रोटोकॉल। कंप्यूटरटर्स
जो है इनके केस में प्रोटोकॉल्स में ऐसे
कुछ प्रोटोकॉल्स होते हैं। जैसे एससीटीपी
एक प्रोटोकॉल हो गया, एसीटीपीएस प्रोटोकॉल
हो गया, डीएनएस प्रोटोकॉल हो गया,
एसएसटीपी प्रोटोकॉल हो गया, एसएसएसएच
प्रोटोकॉल हो गया, एफटीपी प्रोटोकॉल हो
गया, एसएफटीपी प्रोटोकॉल हो गया, एसएमटीपी
प्रोटोकॉल हो गया। तो देयर आर
डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट काइंड्स ऑफ़ प्रोटोकॉल्स
इन टर्म्स ऑफ़ कंप्यूटरटर्स। ठीक है? अब
चलिए विदाउट प्रोटोकॉल्स डिवाइसेस वुड नॉट
अंडरस्टैंड ईच अदर। सिंपल सा फंडा है।
जैसे बिना लैंग्वेज के दो अगर सेम
लैंग्वेज नहीं होते हैं दो लोगों के तो वो
एक दूसरे को क्या ही समझेंगे? अभी एक मान
लो हिंदी में बोल रहा है। दूसरा जो है
फारसी में बोल रहा है। तीसरा जो है वो
चाइनीस बोल रहा है। चौथा जो है वो अलग ही
लैंग्वेज बोल रहा है। कोई फॉरेन लैंग्वेज
बोल रहा है। तो कहां से समझेंगे एक दूसरे
की बात? इट इट इज़ नॉट पॉसिबल। सो दैट्स
व्हाई प्रोटोकॉल्स आर वेरीेंट फॉर
डिवाइसेस टू कम्युनिकेट विद ईच अदर ओवर अ
नेटवर्क। अब यहां पे कुछ प्रोटोकॉल्स हैं
जो यहां पे मैंने मेंशन करके रखा है। जैसे
कि ये मैं अभी शॉर्ट में बता रहा हूं। फिर
हम इसको डिटेल में भी समझेंगे। जैसे
एचटीटीp एंड एसटीपीएस प्रोटोकॉल डीएनएस
जिसको डोमेन नेम सिस्टम बोलते हैं। ये
ऑलरेडी हमने इसके बारे में थोड़ा जाना था।
एसएमटीपी जो कि एक ईमेल प्रोटोकॉल होता है
जो कि अ जिसके थ्रू आप ईमेल्स वगैरह जो है
वो मेल करते हैं। सिंपल मेल ट्रांसफर
प्रोटोकॉल इसका फुल फॉर्म होता है। फुल
फॉर्म्स देख लीजिएगा। डोमेन एंड सिस्टम ये
सब एफटीपी या एसएफटीपी एक सिक्यर्ड एफटीपी
एक नॉर्मल अनसिक्यर्ड एफटीपी देन यहां पे
आरडीपी रिमोट एक्स्ट्रा प्रोटोकॉल आपका ये
हो गया। एंड देन देयर आर डिफरेंट काइंड्स
ऑफ़ मोर एसएसएच एंड अ एक्सेप्ट्रा
एक्सेप्ट्रा देयर आर मल्टीपल प्रोटोकॉल्स।
तो ये जो प्रोटोकॉल्स हैं ये क्या हैं?
एग्जैक्टली कौन-कौन से प्रोटोकॉल्स हैं?
किस तरीके से काम करते हैं वो हम सब जानने
वाले हैं। अब देखो ये प्रोटोकॉल्स
एक्चुअली कहां पे फिट होते हैं? ये भी
अपने को समझना है कि वेयर दीज़ प्रोटोकॉल्स
एक्चुअली गेट फिट। तो इसको हम समझते हैं।
पहले आपने लास्ट सेशन में जो मैंने लेयर्स
पढ़ाए थे आपको। एक सेकंड मैं इसको मोबाइल
में भी ओपन कर लेता हूं। सो दैट आई कैन
गेट द चैट ऑफ योर्स। लेट मी ओपन द चैट्स।
देखो अभी एक बंदे ने पूछा है
[खांसने की आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] सर आई एम इन डे
फाइव हाउ आई विल गेट द सर्टिफिकेट एज आई
एम 11 डेज बैक इन योर क्लास एज़ आई एम
गोइंग स्लोली एंड क्लियरली कोई बात नहीं
आप स्लोली जाइए स्लोली एंड स्टेडी विन द
रेस तो आप स्लो जाइए स्टडी जाइए
सर्टिफिकेट की चिंता छोड़ दीजिए कोई
सर्टिफिकेट वगैरह हम आपको प्रोवाइड नहीं
करने वाले हैं अगर ऐसी बात आप बोल रहे हो
तो सिर्फ सर्टिफिकेट के ऊपर जाओगे तो आपको
सर्टिफिकेट कभी भी प्रोवाइड नहीं करेंगे
हम। कभी भी नहीं मिलेगी। सर्टिफिकेट की
चिंता अभी क्यों कर रहे हो? पहले यह बताओ।
मैंने आपको बोला है कि मैं सर्टिफिकेट के
रिगार्डिंग कुछ आपको अनाउंसमेंट करूंगा
आफ्टर कंप्लीशन ऑफ़ दिस कोर्स। आप अभी से
सर्टिफिकेट के लिए पूछ रहे हो तो उसका कोई
मतलब नहीं बनता है। अभी दिल्ली दूर है
भाई। अभी सर्टिफिकेट के बारे में बिल्कुल
भूल जाना है। ठीक है? अभी बस नॉलेज लो
सीखो। एंड दैट्स इट। आगे बढ़ते जाओ।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके?
गॉट इट।
बहुत बढ़िया। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अब ये प्रोटोकॉल्स कहां पर फिट होते हैं?
देखो, वेब प्रोटोकॉल्स ऑपरेट अक्रॉस
लेयर्स ऑफ द ओएसआई मॉडल। अब पिछले सेशन
में मैंने आपको TCP मॉडल, टीसीpआईपी मॉडल,
ओएसआई मॉडल बताया था। अब उसी ओएसआई मॉडल
में आपके ये प्रोटोकॉल्स फिट होते हैं।
जैसे अब मैं अगर लेयर्स की बात करूं ओएसआई
लेयर्स की एप्लीकेशन लेयर की बात करूं।
राइट? एप्लीकेशन लेयर में एचटीपी,
एचटीपीएस, डीएनएस, एफटीपी जैसे जो
प्रोटोकॉल्स हैं वो फिट होते हैं।
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर में टीसीp, यूडीपी जैसे
प्रोटोकॉल्स काम करते हैं। नेटवर्क लेयर
में आईपी प्रोटोकॉल्स काम करते हैं। मतलब
आईपी इंटरनेट प्रोटोकॉल ही हो गया। डेटा
लिंक लेयर में इथर एंड वाई-फाई जैसी चीजें
काम करती हैं। तो ये ओएसआई लेयर्स में इस
तरीके से क्या करते हैं? ऑपरेट करते हैं
या वर्क करते हैं। अब यहां पे हम कुछ कॉमन
प्रोटोकॉल्स की बात करते हैं। इन कॉमन
प्रोटोकॉल्स में कुछ प्रोटोकॉल्स बहुत
ज्यादा कॉमन एंड बहुत ज्यादा यूज्ड होते
हैं। हर दिन आप यूज़ करते हैं। हर सेकंड आप
यूज़ करते हैं। इनके बिना तो आपका काम
चलेगा भी नहीं। जिसमें सबसे टॉप पे एंड
सबसे बड़ी प्रोटोकॉल आती है जो कि है HTTP
जिस पे पूरा इंटरनेट चल रहा होता है। पूरी
वेबसाइट जो भी आप वेबसाइट ओपन करते हैं
सरफेस वेब पे वो HTTP पे काम कर रहा होता
है मोस्टली। तो यहां पे HTTP का मतलब होता
है हाइपर टेक्स्ट ट्रांसफर प्रोटोकॉल। एंड
क्या है ये? एचटीटीp इज़ द कोर वेब
प्रोटोकॉल यूज़्ड टू ट्रांसफर वेब पेजेस।
जो भी वेब पेजेस आप रीड करते हैं वेब
पेजेस के लिए ये HTTP प्रोटोकॉल यूज़ में
आती है। तो ये पोर्ट नंबर 80 पे काम करती
है। अब देखो हर प्रोटोकॉल जो काम करती है
ना जैसे हर चीज का एक तरीका होता है जिसको
हम प्रोटोकॉल बोलते हैं। अब उस प्रोटोकॉल
जो वो प्रोटोकॉल है वो एक पर्टिकुलर पोर्ट
पे क्या करती है? काम करती है। एक
पर्टिकुलर पोर्ट उससे कनेक्टेड होती है।
हर प्रोटोकॉल्स जो होते हैं हर प्रोटोकॉल
वेब प्रोटोकॉल जो आप होते हैं आपके या
नेटवर्क प्रोटोकॉल बोल लो वो एक पोर्ट
नंबर से एसोसिएटेड होता है। ठीक है? दैट्स
इट। प्रोटोकॉल को एज अ आप सर्विस भी बोल
सकते हो। तो हर एक सर्विस एक पोर्ट से
एसोसिएटेड है। हर सर्विस का एक पोर्ट नंबर
होता है। वो एक यूनिक पोर्ट नंबर होता है।
मतलब अगर ये 80 पोर्ट नंबर एचटीटीपी का है
तो यह किसी और का पोर्ट नंबर नहीं हो
सकता। या 80 पे कोई और पोर्ट नंबर जनरली
काम नहीं करता है। ये जनरली एक स्टैंडर्ड
इसका डेफिनेशन है। एक स्टैंडर्ड एक
कांसेप्ट है। ठीक है? तो हर प्रोटोकॉल का
जितने भी प्रोटोकॉल है वो एक पोर्ट से
एसोसिएटेड होते हैं। तो यहां पे एचटीटीपी
प्रोटोकॉल जो है आपका वो 80 पोर्ट से आपका
एसोसिएटेड है। पोर्ट नंबर 80 इज़ देयर।
राइट?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
अब ये जो पोर्ट है इसको हम स्टेटलेस पोर्ट
बोलते हैं क्योंकि इसको कोई फर्क नहीं
पड़ता है। आपने कौन सी रिक्वेस्ट
भेजी थी क्या भेजी थी? कुछ याद नहीं रखता
ये। इसलिए स्टेटलेस कहा जाता है। इस पे हम
आएंगे थोड़ी देर में। बट ये एचटीटीp
प्रोटोकॉल होता है। अब देखो एचटीटीp
प्रोटोकॉल एक्चुअली काम कैसे करता है?
इसको भी थोड़ा हम देख लेते हैं। इस इमेज
के थ्रू देख लेते हैं। तो यहां पे पांच
स्टेप मैंने आपको दिखाया है। तो पहला जो
है आपका ये क्लाइंट है जो कि एक ब्राउज़र
हो सक होता है। आप ब्राउज़र के थ्रू
एक्सेस करते हो। दूसरा आपका एचटीटीपी हो
गया इटसेल्फ प्रोटोकॉल। तीसरा आपका सर्वर
जो हो गया जहां पे आप रीच आउट कर रहे होते
हो। राइट? अब देखो यहां पे फर्स्ट थिंग
क्या होती है? यूजर इशूज़ यूआरएल फ्रॉम अ
ब्राउज़र। अब आप एज अ यूजर हो। आपने Chrome
ब्राउज़र खोला। आपने उसमें एक यूआरएल ओपन
किया। एक वेबसाइट ओपन की एंड वहां पे ये
वेबसाइट ओपन करने के लिए आपने डाल दिया।
पहला यह आपने काम किया। दूसरा काम क्या
होता है? ब्राउज़र सेंड्स अ रिक्वेस्ट
मैसेज। ब्राउज़र जो है एक रिक्वेस्ट मैसेज
सेंड करता है। अब देखो ब्राउज़र रिक्वेस्ट
मैसेज जो सेंड कर रहा है ना और आपने जो
यूआरएल डाला उसके बीच में भी एक डीएनएस
वाली चीज होती है। डीएनएस का काम होता है
डोमेन नेम सिस्टम का जो कि डोमेन को आईपी
पे मैप करता है। उसके बारे में हम डीएनएस
वाले प्रोटोकॉल में समझेंगे। इस दोनों के
बीच का जो स्टेप है ना वो अभी हम नहीं देख
रहे हैं। हम सीधा एक स्टेप आगे बढ़ जा रहे
हैं। मतलब हम आगे की तरफ बढ़ जा रहे हैं।
इन नंबर वन स्टेप एंड नंबर टू स्टेप के
बीच में भी एक स्टेप है जिसको डीएनएस
स्टेप बोलते हैं। डीएनएस वहां पे ऑपरेट कर
रही होती है। उसके बारे में हम बाद में
समझेंगे। फिलहाल यूजर ने यहां पे वेबसाइट
डाला एंड ब्राउज़र ने एक रिक्वेस्ट सेंड
करी। रिक्वेस्ट कुछ इस तरीके की दिखती है।
गेट यूआरएल एचटीटीp वन वन। यहां पे एक
एचटीपी मेथड होता है। यूआरएल एंड http का
वर्जन होता है। उसके बाद होस्ट यानी कि
किस होस्ट से बेसिकली किस पर्टिकुलर सर्वर
से कनेक्ट होना चाहते हैं या किसको भेज
रहे हैं रिक्वेस्ट जैसे Google को तो उसका
IP एंड पोर्ट या उसका डोमेन एंड पोर्ट जो
भी होता है वो IP एंड पोर्ट के फॉर्म में
ही होता है। डोमेन भी होगा तो आईपी पोर्ट
के फॉर्म में ही होता है। एक रिक्वेस्ट
जाती है। उसके बाद सर्वर मैप्स द यूआरएल
टू अ फाइल और प्रोग्राम अंडर डॉक्यूमेंट
डायरेक्टरी। अब सर्वर क्या करता है? उस
यूआरएल को अगर जैसे आपने लॉगिन करने के
लिए एक रिक्वेस्ट सेंड किया ब्राउज़र के
थ्रू तो लॉगिन डॉट php अब सर्वर के जो रूट
डायरेक्टरी में या पब्लिक डायरेक्टरी जो
भी उसका मेन डायरेक्टरी है जहां डेटाबेस
है उसमें जो लॉगिन डॉट पीएp वाली पेज होगी
उस पे रीडायरेक्ट कर देती है सर्वर सिंपल
सा फंडा है। अब सर्वर क्या करती है? सर्वर
जब रीडायरेक्ट कर देती है तो सर्वर
रिटर्न्स अ रिस्पांस मैसेज। अब सर्वर
रिस्पांस मैसेज रिटर्न करता है जिसमें HTP
1 यानी HTP का वर्जन एंड 200 ओके जो कि एक
स्टेटस कोड HTP का होता है वो रिटर्न करती
है। मतलब कि यस जो आपने रिक्वेस्ट करी थी
वो रिक्वेस्ट फुलफिल मैंने कर दी है। वो
जो रिसोर्सेज आप फैच करने चाह रहे थे वो
फैच हो पा रहे हैं और मेरे पास अवेलेबल थे
इसलिए मैंने 200 ओके दिया। अदरवाइज अगर
नहीं होते मान लो अवेलेबल ही नहीं होते
रिसोर्स तो 44 44 404 नॉट फाउंड जो आपने
देखा होगा यूजुअली एरर बहुत सारी
वेबसाइट्स ओपन करते हैं पेज ओपन करते हैं
तो आपको 404 नॉट फाउंड करके आता है। कई
लोगों को लगता है कि 40 ये याद हो गया
होगा। कई लोगों को तो पता भी है कि 404
नॉट फाउंड मतलब यहां पे नहीं अवेलेबल वो
चीज़। लेकिन इसका एक्चुअली मतलब होता है।
वो एक स्टेटस कोड होता है जिसका एक मतलब
होता है। उसके बारे में भी हम जानेंगे आज
के इस सेशन में। तो ये हमें रिस्पांस देता
है। बाद में ब्राउज़र जो है रिस्पांस को
फॉर्मेट करता है और उसको डिस्प्ले कर देता
है यूजर को। ब्राउज़र क्या करता है? ले भाई
तुमने Facebook.com login. Php के लिए
रिक्वेस्ट भेजा। रिक्वेस्ट गई सर्वर के
डायरेक्टरी में और सर्वर के डायरेक्टरी
में लॉगिन. पीएp पेज अवेलेबल थी। अब सर्वर
ने उस पेज के कंटेंट को फेच करके आपको
रिस्पांस दे दिया। यानी कि यूज़र्स को इन
यूजर को ब्राउज़र ने क्या किया? सामने दिखा
दिया कि भैया लॉगिन पीएp का एक Facebook
का पेज है। अब यह पूरा जो प्रोसेस है भैया
यह पूरा प्रोसेस पता है कितने यह पूरी जो
बीच की प्रोसेस है ये कितने दूर की है?
मतलब कब हो रही है ये मैं आपको दिखाता
हूं। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओके। मैंने यहां पे Facebook ओपन किया।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ठीक है।
थोड़ी सी इंटरनेट स्लो है बट थोड़ा
पता नहीं आज क्या हो गया कुछ हुआ है इशू
हुआ है। यहां मैंने Facebook ओपन किया। अब
मैंने फेस देखो सिंपल सा मैं फंडा बताता
हूं। मैंने यहां पे facebook.com
login. Php अगर मैं ओपन करता हूं। मैंने
एंटर जैसे ही किया। एंटर करने के बाद मान
लो ये login. PHP आ गया। देखो यह पेज है
facebook.com login.p ठीक है? यहां पे आप
जब कर्सर मैं लेकर जाऊंगा तो यहां पे टॉप
में जब सॉरी बॉटम में लेफ्ट साइड में आप
देखोगे facebook.com लॉगिन इस पे
रीडायरेक्ट हो रहा है। मतलब ये रीडायरेक्ट
कहां हो रहा है? facebook.com
लॉगिन इस पे हो रहा है। तो जैसे ही मैंने
एंटर किया एंटर करते ही मुझे ये जो पेज
ओपन हुआ ये जो पेज ओपन हुआ यही प्रोसेस
जैसे आपने 1 सेकंड में एंटर किया। 1 सेकंड
में ये पेज आ गई। इस एक सेकंड की ये जो
प्रोसेस है वो प्रोसेस मैंने आपको अभी
बताया है। ये पूरा जो स्टेप हो रहा है ना
पांच स्टेप ये बस ये एक सेकंड की प्रोसेस
का पांच स्टेप है। ठीक है? अब इन इसके
अंदर भी और बहुत कुछ होते हैं। वो भी हम
धीरे-धीरे जान जाएंगे। कोई दिक्कत नहीं।
थ्री वे हैंडशक आप सब ने कई लोगों ने पढ़ा
होगा जाना होगा। तो आपको ऑलरेडी इसके बारे
में आईडिया भी होगा। राइट? तो मजा आ रहा
है? समझ में आ रहा है?
गॉट इट? अच्छा विजिबिलिटी तो सही है ना आप
लोगों को? मतलब मैं क्लियर दिख रहा हूं आप
लोगों को? आप लोगों को कंटेंट क्लियर तो
दिख रहा है ना? मेरे को उससे मतलब है।
कंटेंट तो क्लियर दिख रहा है। आप लोगों को
एक बार यह बता दीजिए।
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] चलिए
हां थोड़ी नेटवर्क स्लो है बट कंटेंट मुझे
क्लियर दिख रही है। इसलिए मैंने आपसे
कंफर्म बस कह लिया शायद कुछ इशू हो। तो
चलिए ठीक है। तो यहां पे हमारे पास ये
प्रोसेस आपको समझ में आ गया। इस तरीके से
हाइपर टेक्स्ट ट्रांसफर प्रोटोकॉल आपकी
काम करती है। एसटीडीपी काम करती है। अब
देखो एचटीटीp में
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
कि जो मैंने चीज आपको वहां बताई सेम चीज
यहां पर ऑलमोस्ट मैं आपको बता रहा हूं
रिटेन फॉर्म में।
ठीक है? स्टेप वन में क्लाइंट रिक्वेस्ट
करता है। ठीक है? ब्राउज़र सेंड रिक्वेस्ट
करता है। कुछ इस तरीके की रिक्वेस्ट होती
है जैसे मैंने अभी पहले बताया आपको और
सर्वर जो है रिसोंड करता है कुछ इस तरीके
से जिसमें कि हेडर होती है और फिर बॉडी
होता है। इसमें भी आपका हेडर एंड बॉडी
होती है। अगर कुछ बॉडी में कुछ जा रहा है
रिक्वेस्ट में तो। तो ये सेम प्रोसेस है
जो मैंने यहां पे आपको ग्राफिकली बताया
वही मैंने यहां पे टाइप करके आपके सामने
रखा है। ठीक है?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
गॉट इट? कोई बात नहीं। अ बंडे बुंडेल
वॉग्स चलता है इतना आप आपने आउट ऑफ
थोड़ा अग्रेशन किया होगा। बट
दिस इज व्हाट एक्चुअली ये कमेंट उस कमेंट
के बारे में बात कर रहे हैं जो
जो इन्होंने एक लास्ट कमेंट बैच में किया
था लास्ट क्लास के कमेंट में किया था
इन्होंने कि सर बच्चों के भविष्य के साथ
खिलवाड़ आप कर रहे हैं क्लासेस नहीं ला
रहे हैं तो मैंने इनको रिप्लाई किया था कि
अगर आपको ऐसा लगता है तो आप बहुत सारे
रिसोर्सेज हैं एसओसी के आप इंटरनेट पे
देखिए क्योंकि मैंने तो ऐसा कुछ सोचा नहीं
था एंड दूसरी चीज एक चीज मैं बोल बोलता
हूं बस कि जस्ट पुट ऑन 200 प्लस कमेंट्स
रियल जेन्युइन कमेंट्स एंड आई एम देयर फॉर
यू। अगर आप उतना भी मेरे कहने पे नहीं कर
पा रहे हैं या मेरे लिए नहीं कर पा रहे
हैं। यूनिक नहीं कर पा रहे हैं। आप फर्जी
वाला काम कर रहे हैं। एक ही बंदा 10 कमेंट
कर रहा है तो फिर क्या फायदा? मतलब मैं
आपसे कुछ और एक्सपेक्ट तो नहीं कर रहा।
मैंने तो आपको बस बोला है वीडियो को शेयर
करने के लिए और 200 कमेंट्स करने के लिए।
वीडियो को शेयर करते रहो और 200 कमेंट्स
करते रहो। वीडियो को शेयर करते रहो तो
उससे सभी तक पहुंचेगा। कमेंट्स कर दोगे तो
आपकी इंगेजमेंट का समझ में आएगा मुझे कि
आप एक्चुअली इंगेज्ड हैं। एक्चुअली
इंटरेस्टेड बहुत ज्यादा है अभी भी। दैट्स
व्हाई राइट? बस उसको थोड़ा सा आप लोग
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] मेंटेन करिएगा
अगर तो अच्छी बात है। अच्छा लगेगा मुझे
भी। नहीं तो फिर मैं क्या बोलूं? ठीक है?
राइट? चलिए।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
[हंसी] सो यहां पे अब क्लाइंट जो है
रिक्वेस्ट करता है सर्वर को एंड सर्वर
रिस्पांस करता है। किसको?
किसको करता है? क्लाइंट को। सिंपल क्लाइंट
रिक्वेस्ट करता है सर्वर को। सर्वर रिसोंड
करता है क्लाइंट को। अब एज अ एसओसी
एनालिस्ट इंडिकेटर्स किस तरीके के आपको
इंडिकेट इंडिकेशन दे सकते हैं? सस्पिशियस
यूआरएल्स का ऑब्वियस सी बात है। एचटीपी पे
बेस्ड है। रिपीटेड रिक्वेस्ट्स का यानी
लॉग इन ब्रूटf वगैरह हो रही है। अनयूजुअल
यूजर एजेंट्स। यूजर एजेंट्स में जनरली
ब्राउज़र्स रिलेटेड क्वेरीज़ ब्राउज़र
रिलेटेड डिटेल्स होती हैं कि किस ब्राउज़र
से कनेक्ट किया जा रहा है। किस ब्राउज़र से
रिक्वेस्ट भेजी जा रही है। तो उसको
बार-बार चेंज करके बेवकूफ बनाया जाता है
सर्वर को। एंड लार्ज पोस्ट रिक्वेस्ट।
पोस्ट रिक्वेस्ट बहुत सारे पोस्ट
रिक्वेस्ट्स होते हैं। हम गेट पोस्ट पे भी
आएंगे। तो वो भी बहुत बड़े-बड़े लार्ज
रिक्वेस्ट्स जाएंगे ताकि कुछ तरह के
प्रॉब्लम्स या डीडीएस अटैक टाइप काइंड ऑफ़
थिंग्स लॉन्च कर दी जाए। इस तरह की चीजें
होती हैं। राइट? अटैक्स एचटीटीपी को लेके
क्या-क्या तरह के अटैक्स हो सकते हैं? तो
भैया देयर आर
वेरियस काइंड ऑफ़ अटैक्स जो वेब अटैक्स
होते हैं वो सारे ही इसमें इंक्लूड कर दो।
जैसे कि एक्सेस हो गया, एस्क्यू इंजेक्शन
हो गया, क्रेडेंशियल हार्वेस्टिंग हो गई,
http फ्लड हो गया या डीडीओएस हो गई। ये
सारी चीजें आप इसमें इंक्लूड कर सकते हैं।
सो अब http के कैसे हम ब्राउज़र जो है ना
रिक्वेस्ट को भेजता है हम उसको भी थोड़ा
समझेंगे कि ब्राउज़र रिक्वेस्ट को कैसे
भेजता है। थोड़ा इसको समझिएगा आपको और मजा
आने वाला है। एक स्टेप इसमें बढ़ जाएगा
देन आपको लेकिन मजा आएगा। ठीक है? चलिए
इसको [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] समझते हैं।
नहीं देखो इंडिकेटर्स याद नहीं करना है
आपको। इंडिकेटर्स का मतलब यहां पे मैं
क्या बताता हूं कि जब कोई भी चीज देखो
मेमोराइज करना दिमाग में फिट करना और
रट्टा लगाना दोनों में बहुत अंतर होता है।
देखो रट्टा लगाना भी एक तरह से मेमोराइज
करना ही हो गया। लेकिन एक मेमोराइज करना
हो गया कि आप रट रहे हो रट के और कुछ टाइम
के बाद आप भूल जाओगे। एक होता है कि उसको
दिमाग के अंदर ना एकदम से स्टेबली फिट कर
देना। ऐसा फिट करना कि ऐसा लगे कि अरे यार
अब तो ये चीज परमानेंट हो गई मेरे साथ। तो
वो प्रैक्टिस पे होती है। वो टाइम के साथ
और प्रैक्टिस के साथ वो आपके दिमाग में छप
जाएगा। जब एक बार छप जाएगा तो वो कभी बाहर
नहीं जाएगा। बस उसी तरीके से इंडिकेटर्स
पे जब जब प्रैक्टिस आपके होने लगेंगे तो
ऑटोमेटिकली आपको मजा आने लगेगा। अब यहां
पे आते हैं हाउ ब्राउज़र सेंड्स रिक्वेस्ट।
रिक्वेस्ट कैसे सेंड करता है? देखो
ब्राउज़र में आप जैसे ही कोई यूआरएल डालते
हैं तो अब जो है ये क्या करता है? डीएनएस
के ऊपर यह रिक्वेस्ट जाती है। सिंपल सा
फंडा है। यह डीएनएस के ऊपर रिक्वेस्ट जाती
है। अब यह डीएनएस को फाइंड करने लगता है
कि भैया कौन सा है डीएनएस रिॉल्व। कौन सा
है डीएनएस सर्वर? भाई कौन सा है हमारा
लोकल डीएनएस सर्वर? जल्दी बताओ कहां पे है
वो? और खोजने लगता है। साथ ही ब्राउज़र का
अपना एक कैश मेमोरी होता है। उस कैश
मेमोरी को एक्सेस करता है। ठीक है? उस कैश
मेमोरी में एक्चुअली क्या होता है कि वो
डोमेन किस आईपी से मैप्ड थी? उसकी डिटेल
होती है। तो अगर कैश मेमोरी में उस डोमेन
की आईपी प्रेजेंट है या डोमेन मैप्ड किस
आईपी पे है यह पता है तो ब्राउज़र अपने कैश
मेमोरी से ही उस डिटेल को फैच कर लेगा और
डीएनएस वाली सारी कहानी खत्म हो जाएगी।
डीएनएस का कोई काम नहीं है। डीएनएस जॉबलेस
हो जाएगा उस टाइम पे। डीएनएस वाली सर्वर
की किसी काम डीएनएस सर्वर किसी काम की उस
टाइम में है ही नहीं। बट अगर ब्राउज़र कैश
में ये वाली इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं है कि ये
डोमेन किस IP पे मैप्ड है यानी किस IP से
कनेक्ट करनी है क्योंकि पता ही था मैंने
बताया था कि कंप्यूटर जो सर्वर्स होते हैं
वो IP जानते हैं। आप डोमेन डालते हो वो IP
खोजता है और उसी कॉस्पोंडिंग आईपी से
कनेक्ट करता है जो कि सर्वर की आईपी होती
है। तो ये आईपी अगर मिल गई तो ठीक है।
नहीं मिली तो अब जो भैया है ये डीएनएस
सर्वर के पास जाते हैं। आपके
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] डीएनएस सर्वर के
पास।
अब डीएनएस सर्वर जो होते हैं इनका भी एक
कैश होता है। कैश मेमोरी होता है। हर
सर्वर का एक कैश मेमोरी होता है। बस इतना
आपको समझ के रखना है जिसको डीएनएस कैश
बोलते हैं। अब डीएनएस सर्वर जो है अपने
कैश में खोजते हैं कि भैया इस डोमेन की
आईपी है क्या? अगर कैश में आईपी मिल गई तो
इसको रिसोंड कर देते हैं कि लो भाई
तुम्हारी आईपी मिल गई। अगर नहीं मिली तो
यहां से शुरू होता है डीएनएस हायरार्की
डीएनएस रिॉल्विंग एंड वहां से डिॉल्व
होते-होते वो एक अलग प्रोसेस है। किस
तरीके से रिॉल्व होती है वो भी मैं आपको
बताऊंगा। वो एक पूरा स्टेप बताऊंगा ताकि
आपको समझ में आ जाएगा। तो डीएनएस के
रिॉल्विंग के कुछ स्टेप्स होते हैं। तो
डीएनएस उन स्टेप्स के थ्रू उस पर्टिकुलर
डोमेन का आईपी खोज के निकालता है और फिर
ब्राउज़र को भेजता है यानी कि क्लाइंट को
भेजता है और क्लाइंट उस कनेक्ट करता है उस
आईपी से उस सर्वर को। सिंपल सा रिस्पांस।
तो यहां पे अब ये लाइक टीसीपी कनेक्शन
करके एसटीडीp पे रिस्पांस कर देता है। ये
कर देता है। ये तो डीएनएस सर्वर का नॉर्मल
सा आ गया कि बीच में एक डीएनएस सर्वर आ
गया। अब इसने आईपी खोज दी। एंड दैट्स इट।
लेकिन डीएनएस आईपी खोजता कैसे है? द मेन
थिंग इज़ दिस आल्सो कि हाउ डीएनएस एक्चुअली
फाइंड्स द आईपी। तो ये भी जो है ना 100
टारगेट 100 लाइक्स का टारगेट। हां यार आज
लाइक्स 100 नहीं हुए हैं। दिस इज़ वेरी
वेरी वेरी
वियर्ड।
बहुत
बहुत रेयर्ड है यार। इतनी कम लेग्स कैसे
हैं?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
हम हम
हा [गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
आज क्लास जल्दी हुई तो लाइक्स कम है। वाह!
यह यह तो लॉजिक गजब समझ नहीं आया मुझे यह
लॉजिक। ठीक है कोई बात नहीं है। अब यहां
पे आपको पता चला। देखो पहले आपको क्या पता
चला था यहां पे कि एक क्लाइंट है। बीच में
एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट रिक्वेस्ट हो रही है।
फिर सर्वर से रिस्पांस आ रहा है। यहां पे
कम्युनिकेशन हो चुकी है। यहां पे आपका
रिस्पांस आ गया। अब पता चला कि बीच में एक
डीएनएस आ चुका है। डोमेन नेम सिस्टम जो
डोमेन को आईपी में कन्वर्ट करता है। अभी
के लिए इतना समझो। एक नॉर्मल लेमन
लैंग्वेज में कि डीएनएस का काम है डोमेन
को IP में कन्वर्ट करना। बेसिकली यह
कन्वर्ट नहीं होता है। डोमेन को मैप किया
जाता है IP के ऊपर में एंड वहां पे उस
पर्टिकुलर डोमेन के कॉस्पोंडिंग जो IP
एड्रेस होती है उसको वो बताता है ब्राउज़र
को। एंड उस तरीके से ये काम करता है। चलिए
अब यहां पे आते हैं एचटीटीपी मेथड्स के
ऊपर समझते हैं। एचटीटीपी मेथड क्या है? हम
उस वाले डीएनएस वाले को भी याद रखना। उस
पे भी हम आएंगे कैसे करता है? वो सब भी हम
देखेंगे। तो एचटीपी डिफाइन अ सेट ऑफ
रिक्वेस्ट मेथड्स टू इंडिकेट द पर्पस ऑफ द
रिक्वेस्ट एंड व्हाट इज एक्सपेक्टेड इफ द
रिक्वेस्ट इज़ सक्सेसफुल। तो एचटीटीपी ने
एक रिक्वेस्ट मेथड
को बेसिकली डिफाइन किया है। एचटीपी के
इसने क्या किया है कि
डिफाइन अ सेट ऑफ़ रिक्वेस्ट मेथड टू
इंडिकेट द पर्पस ऑफ़ द रिक्वेस्ट। मतलब अब
रिक्वेस्ट आप किसी से कुछ रिक्वेस्ट कर
रहे हो। ठीक है? व्हाटएवर रिक्वेस्ट यू आर
डूइंग जस्ट अ सेकंड।
[खांसने की आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
सॉरी
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
हां अब किसी से कोई रिक्वेस्ट आप कर रहे
हो तो उसका कुछ तो पर्पस होगा कि व्हाई यू
आर रिक्वेस्टिंग? उसी तरीके से जो
रिक्वेस्ट क्लाइंट करता है सर्वर से तो
उसका कुछ मतलब होता है, पर्पस होता है। उस
पर्पस को हम एचटीटीपी मेथड्स के थ्रू
समझते हैं। एचटीटीपी मेथड्स के थ्रू उस
पर्पस को हम समझते हैं। सो, एचटीटीपी
डिफाइन अ सेट ऑफ़ रिक्वेस्ट मेथड्स टू
इंडिकेट द पर्पस ऑफ़ द रिक्वेस्ट्स एंड
व्हाट इज़ एक्सपेक्टेड इफ रिक्वेस्ट इज़
सक्सेसफुल। मतलब जो रिक्वेस्ट हम कर रहे
हैं सर्वर से उसका जो पर्पस है वह
एचटीटीपी मेथड के थ्रू डिफाइन होता है। और
यह भी डिफाइन होता है कि अगर वह रिक्वेस्ट
सक्सेसफुल हो जाती है अगर सर्वर ने बोला
ठीक है आई एम गोइंग टू फुलफिल योर
रिक्वेस्ट तो उस तो फिर मतलब क्या
एक्सपेक्ट कर सकते हैं? दिस इज़ कॉल्ड
एचटीटीपी मेथड्स।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] अब एचटीटीपी
मेथड्स में देयर आर सेवरल एचटीटीपी मेथड।
बहुत सारे होते हैं। कुछ कॉमन एसटीडीपी
मेथड्स मैंने यहां पे डाले हैं। हालांकि
आपको बहुत डेप्थ में नहीं जाना है। बट याद
रखना कि सेशन के बाद खुद से जो एक्सप्लोर
करने वाली टास्क मैं देता हूं उसमें ये
आपका एक टास्क है कि एसटीडीपी मेथड्स के
बारे में आपको समझना है।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] पढ़ना है। कैसे
काम करते हैं और अगर आपको कहीं और से नहीं
पढ़ना। अगर आपको डिफ्रॉनिक से ही पढ़ना है
तो उसका भी मैं आपको
तरीका बता देता हूं। सिंपल आपको उसका
तरीका है। YouTube पर जाना है।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
यहां पर डेफ्रोनिक्स सर्च कर लेना है।
डेफ्रॉनिक्स में यहां पे आ जाना है आपको
लाइव वाले सेक्शन पे चले जाना है। एंड
यहां पे आपको सर्च पे आके लैपटॉप पे ही
सर्च होता है। यहां पे देखना है लिखना
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] है एचटीdटीp।
http लिखेंगे तो यहां पे एक आपको एक सेशन
मिलेगी http [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
यस।
एचटीपी स्टेटस कोड्स यह एक आपको मिलेगी और
http हेडर्स यह दो आपको यहां पे वीडियोस
मिलेंगे। ठीक है? तो इसमें से जो आपका
एचटीटीपी हेडर वाला आपका जो अ बेसिकली ये
सेशन है एचटीटीपी हेडर वाली आप इसको देख
लीजिएगा। एचटीटीपी
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] हेडर वाले में
बहुत कुछ आपको मिल जाएगा एंड एचटीपी
स्टेटस कोड्स इन दोनों वीडियोस को आप देख
लीजिएगा। इसमें आपको ओवरऑल सारी चीजें
नॉलेज मिल जाएगी जो मैं आपको बोल रहा हूं
एज अ प्रैक्टिस करने के लिए या यू कैन से
कि एज अ एक्सप्लोर करने के लिए। खुद से भी
आप एक्सप्लोर कर सकते हैं। इंटरनेट पे
रिसोर्सेज भरे पड़े हैं। आप वहां से भी ले
सकते हैं। बट आपको बहुत डीप में नहीं जाना
है क्योंकि ये बहुत डीप टॉपिक्स हैं। बहुत
डीप में भी आप जा सकते हैं। बट आपको इतना
डीप में एज अ एसओसी एल1 आपको रिक्वायर्ड
नहीं पड़ेगा। तो मेथड्स में देयर आर
वेरियस मेथड्स जिसके थ्रू रिक्वेस्ट जो है
वो जाती है। एक गेट होता है, एक पोस्ट
होता है, एक पुट है, डिलीट है, पैच है।
देयर आर डिफरेंट मेथड्स। अब गेट मेथड का
मतलब है डेटा जो फेच करती है। पोस्ट का जो
डेटा सेंड करती है, पुट अपडेट करती है
रिसोर्सेज को। डिलीट जो रिमूव करती है
रिसोर्सेज को। पैच जो पार्शियल अपडेट करती
है। सो देयर आर मल्टीपल मेथड्स मतलब कि
गेट मेथड्स। अब जैसे आप कोई भी
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] देखो
मैं आपको यहां पे लाइव दिखा देता हूं।
ओके? आई एम गोइंग टू शो यू लाइव
डेमोंस्ट्रेशन ऑफ इट।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] मैं यहां पे कोई
भी वेबसाइट ओपन करता हूं। मान लो मैं
डिफ्रॉनिक्स ओपन कर रहा हूं। ठीक है? अब
मैं डिफ्रॉनिक्स मैंने ओपन किया। अब मैं
यहां पे इसके मोर टूल्स पे चल के एंड
डेवलपर टूल्स को ओपन कर लेता हूं। जब मैं
डेवलपर टूल को ओपन करूंगा यहां पे तो आप
देख रहे होंगे नेटवर्क टैब है। अब मैं
इसको वापस से रीलोड करता हूं। जैसे ही मैं
रीलोड करूंगा, यहां पे डिफरेंट-डिफ़ेंट जो
है आपके अह
रिसोर्सेज यहां पे लोड होते हैं एंड हमें
देखने को मिलेंगे। तो मैं यहां पे फिलहाल
के लिए
लेट्स गो टू द एकडमी। इफ देयर इज़ सम
ओके यहां पे चलते हैं। मोर टूल्स डेवलपर
टूल्स। लेट्स रीलोड इट। लेट्स सी इफ देयर
इज़ समथिंग।
ओके।
ओके। लेट्स ओपन इट।
ओके। ओनली सॉकेट्स आर सिलेक्टेड। सॉकेट
सिलेक्टेड है इसलिए ऐसा हो रहा है। मैं ऑल
पे कर देता हूं। हां। चलिए यहां पे गलती
से सॉकेट्स सिलेक्टेड हो गया था। इस वजह
से कुछ आ नहीं रहा था हमारे पास। अब
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] मान लो यहां पे
मेरे पास मैंने रिक्वेस्ट किया। मैं इसको
हटा देता हूं। मैं यहीं पे आ जाता हूं
यहां पे। एंड इसको मैं सॉकेट से हटा के ऑल
पे कर देता हूं। एंड मैं यहां पे रीलोड कर
देता हूं वापस से। तो अब यहां पे देखो
यहां पे रिक्वेस्ट लोड हो रही हैं।
डिफरेंट मैं dfinish.com यहां पे मान लो
रिक्वेस्ट है। अब रिक्वेस्ट देखो
रिक्वेस्ट जो जा रही है वो किस तरीके से
जा रही है? ये हेडर है। तो dfin.com को जा
रही है। रिक्वेस्ट मेथड कौन सा यूज़ हो रहा
है? तो गेट रिक्वेस्ट मेथड यूज़ हो रहा है।
तो उसी तरीके से ये मेथड्स होते हैं।
अलग-अलग रिक्वेस्ट टाइप के लिए अलग-अलग
मेथड्स होते हैं। अब मान लो रिस्पांस में
आओगे। मैं रिस्पांस पे आता हूं। तो यहां
पे रिस्पांस के में ऊपर के साइड चलते हैं।
एंड यहां पे कुछ इस तरीके से ये hटीएमएल
या जो भी डॉक्यूमेंट्स है वो रिस्पांस आ
रही है। तो ये हेडर्स में रिक्वेस्ट
हेडर्स आपकी यहां पे जनरल हेडर्स में गेट
देख रहे हो यहां पे। यहां पे आपको ये
रिस्पांस हेडर मिलेगा। एंड फिर यहां पे
आपको रिक्वेस्ट हेडर इसमें भी आपको गेट
मेथड जो है ये क्या मिल रही है? गेट मेथड
क्या है भैया आपकी? तो ये आपकी एचटीटीपी
मेथड्स है। आपको यहां पे दिख रहा होगा
रिक्वेस्ट मेथड एस गेट। तो इस तरीके से
मेथड्स होते हैं। अब मैं मान लो यहां पे
चल के एंड लेट्स सी मैं चलता हूं एकडमी पे
एंड यहां पे मैं वापस से डेवलपर टूल्स पे
जाता हूं। लेट्स रीलोड इट।
देखा तो अब यहां पे मान लो कोर्सर्सेस
वगैरह आ रही। तो यहां पे देखो ये भी गेट
मेथड है। अब मैं इसी पे चल के मैं यहां पे
इसको ऐसे करके इस पे चलते हैं। एकडमी पे
लॉग इन पे क्लिक करते हैं। ठीक है? अब
मैंने लॉग इन पे क्लिक किया। अब ये लॉग इन
आ गया। मैं यहां पे मोर टूल्स करके डेवलप
डेवलपर ऑप्शन पे जाता हूं। अब यहां पे
चलते हैं। यहां पे ये गेट मेथड आ गया।
यहां पे गेट गेट आ रहा है। गेट ठीक है?
गेट गेट गेट गेट
गेट मेथड आ गया। मैं यहां पे कोई यहां पे
लॉग इन का पेज ढूंढना पड़ेगा थोड़ा सा। अ
नथिंग देयर।
अब यहां हां यहां पर गेट अब देखो जैसे
यहां पे मेरे पास एक गेट मेथड आया है। ठीक
है? अब गेट मेथड में दो चीज है। अब देखो
एक चीज जो आ रही है एक गेट मेथड आ रहा है
और दूसरा जो स्टेटस कोड आ रहा है वो 200
हो के आ रहा है। इसका मतलब है कि इस पेज
को एक्सेस किया गया है। इस रिसोर्स को
एक्सेस किया गया है। बट वहीं पे यहां पे
हम आएंगे तो यहां पे गेट मेथड से इंटैक्ट
तो हो रही है। बट यहां पे 403 फॉरमिडेडन आ
जा रहा है। यहां पे जो स्टेटस कोड आ रहा
है कुछ 403 करके आ रहा है। तो हम इसको भी
समझेंगे। स्टेटस कोड्स वगैरह क्या होते
हैं? किस तरीके से काम करते हैं? वी विल
अंडरस्टैंड दैट आल्सो वी विल बी कमिंग टू
दैट पॉइंट वेरी वेरी सून। पहले हम इसको
देख लेते हैं।
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ठीक है? ये मेथड्स होते हैं जिसके थ्रू
क्या होते हैं? एक रिक्वेस्ट का पर्पस पता
चलता है। जो भी एक रिक्वेस्ट होती है जो
क्लाइंट करता है सर्वर को उसका एक पर्पस
पता चलता है। और अगर रिक्वेस्ट सक्सेसफुल
हो जाती है तो क्या एक्सपेक्ट कर सकते हैं
वो पता चल जाता है। इसके बारे में थोड़ा
एक्सप्लोर कीजिएगा आप लोग खुद से भी। हां।
अब एचटीडीटीp मैंने पहले ही बोला था एक
स्टेटलेस प्रोटोकॉल है। स्टेटलेस
प्रोटोकॉल का मतलब है एचटीडीटीp डज़ नॉट
रिमेंबर हु यू आर प्रीवियस रिक्वेस्ट।
उसको आप कौन हो? क्या उसको कोई फर्क नहीं
पड़ता है। दे डोंट रिमेंबर एंड प्रीवियस
रिक्वेस्ट क्या थी वो भी वो रिमाइंड वो भी
वो याद नहीं रखता है। बस इतना पता होना
चाहिए। दैट्स व्हाई वी यूज़ कुकीज़ सेशंस
एंड टोकंस। क्योंकि ये स्टेटलेस प्रोटोकॉल
है। इसको कुछ याद नहीं रहता। तो याद करने
के लिए हम अलग-अलग तरह के हथकंडे अपनाते
हैं। अलग-अलग तरह की चीजों को करते हैं।
वो है जैसे कि कुकीज़, सेशंस, टोकंस इन तरह
की चीजों को यूज़ करते हैं। कुकीज़ में
कुकीज़ के अंदर भी इनेशन होती है। सेशंस के
अंदर भी इनेशन होता है, टोकंस के अंदर भी
इनेशन होती है या यूं कहें कि कोई इनेशन
ट्रैवल कर रही होती है किसी भी तरह का। तो
वो हम चीजें यूज़ करते हैं क्योंकि दिस इज़
अ स्टेटलेस प्रोटोकॉल। सिंपल।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] अब बात करते हैं
एचटीटीपी के स्टेटस कोड्स को जो कि हम
वहां देख रहे एक बार 200 ओके था। एक बार
401 एक बार 401 था। 403 होता है। 402
अलग-अलग स्टेटस कोड्स होते हैं। तो हम
उसको देखते हैं। भाई ये क्या है? देखो अब
एचटीपी रिस्पांस स्टेटस कोड्स इंडिकेट
वेदर अ स्पेसिफिक एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट हैज़
बीन सक्सेसफुली कंप्लीटेड। मतलब एचटीपी जो
स्टेटस कोड्स होते हैं ये रिस्पांस स्टेटस
कोड कहलाते हैं। मतलब कि जैसे आपने कोई
रिक्वेस्ट भेजा तो अब वो रिक्वेस्ट फुलफिल
अगर हो रही है तो 200 मतलब ओके नहीं हो
रही है तो इट्स इट माइट बी 403 इट माइट बी
इट माइट बी 404 और इट माइट बी 50 सर्वर के
साइड से एरर हो सकती है। तो इस कुछ भी हो
सकता है। इसका मतलब ये हुआ कि सर्वर आपको
स्टेटस कोड के फॉर्म में ना रिसोंड करती
है कि भैया ये नहीं हो पाएगा। नहीं मिल
पाएगा आपको इसकी आंसर। इसकी इसकी डिटेल
आपको नहीं मिल पाएगी। इसका ये सब चीजें हम
मुझे नहीं पता। तो वो स्टेटस कोड्स के
फॉर्म में रिसोंड करता है। अब इन स्टेटस
कोड्स को जो ये रिस्पांससेस हैं इनको
ग्रुप डिवाइड किया गया है। पांच ग्रुप्स
में। ये पांच ग्रुप्स में डिवाइड किए गए
हैं। पहले जो ग्रुप का है वो है
इंफॉर्मेशनेशनल रिस्पांससेस होते हैं।
दूसरा सक्सेसफुल होता है। तीसरा
रीडायरेक्शनल मैसेजेस होते हैं। चौथा
क्लाइंट एरर रिस्पांस होता है। और पांचवा
जो है वो आपका सर्वर एरर रिस्पांस होता
है। ये चीजें ये आपको दिमाग में बैठाना
पड़ेगा। अब रिस्पांस कोड्स जो होते हैं
इंफॉर्मेशनेशनल रिस्पांस कोड्स जो होते
हैं 100 से लेकर 199 तक होते हैं। ये
इंफॉर्मेशनेशनल होते हैं। अगर आपको कोई
ऐसा रिस्पांस कोड आ रहा है जो 100 से 199
है तो दैट दैट माइट नॉट बी डेंजरस दैट नॉट
माइट नॉट बी ऑफ़ एनी काइंड ऑफ़ लाइक वरी एंड
सही है। ओके अगर 200 से 299 तक कोई
रिस्पांस कोड आ रहा है। मतलब वो ओके मतलब
वो पॉजिटिव सेंस में है। ओके है। सही है।
चलेगा मस्त दौड़ेगा। लेकिन अगर 300 से 399
तक का कोई स्टेटस कोड्स आ रहा है तो इसका
मतलब है कि एक वेबसाइट या एक वेब पेज को
किसी तरीके से रीडायरेक्ट किया जा रहा है।
जैसे अगर मान लो मैं dfonic.com ओपन करूं
और मेरे dfonic.com ओपन करने से
google.com ओपन हो जाए रीडायरेक्ट हो के
तो ये रीडायरेक्शन कहलाता है। एक वेबसाइट
को दूसरे वेबसाइट पे रीडायरेक्ट कर देना
लेकर जाना। तो अगर इस तरह की कोई चीज होती
है जैसे सर्वर्स या वेब डेवलपर्स क्या
करते हैं कि कोई पुरानी अगर वेब वेबसाइट
है या वेब एड्रेस है और नई एड्रेस पे उनको
रीडायरेक्ट करना है तो एसटी एक्सेस पेज के
अंदर या किसी भी तरीके से यूटिलिटीज के
अंदर वो रीडायरेक्ट कर देते हैं। तो वहां
पे वो इन्हीं रीडायरेक्ट जो स्टेटस कोड्स
होते हैं उसको यूज़ करते हैं। रिस्पांस में
आपको वही आएगा कि भैया ये पेज
रीडायरेक्टेड है तो 300 से 399 तक के
कोड्स आ जाएंगे। क्लाइंट एरर रिस्पांस। अब
अगर 400 से 499 तक के कोई रिस्पांस आपको आ
रहा है तो यह क्लाइंट एरर यानी क्लाइंट के
साइड से कोई गलती हो रही है। देखो यानी कि
इसका मतलब है सर्वर सब सही काम कर रहा है।
सर्वर सही काम देखो सर्वर गड़बड़ काम कर
रही है। उसका सिर्फ लास्ट वाला होता है
सर्वर एरर मैसेज। इसका मतलब है सर्वर के
साइड से ही कोई एरर या कोई इशू है।
अदरवाइज बाकी सारे में सर्वर का कोई रोल
नहीं है। सर्वर के साइड से कोई इशू नहीं
होती है। क्लाइंट एरर रिस्पांससेस होते
हैं 400 से 499 तक। यानी जैसे 401, 400,
403, 404 इसका मतलब जैसे बैड रिक्वेस्ट
मतलब आपने कोई ऐसी रिक्वेस्ट करी है जो
आपको नहीं करनी है। मतलब वो बैड रिक्वेस्ट
है वो सही आपने रिक्वेस्ट करी नहीं है।
अनऑथराइज़्ड मतलब आपने कोई ऐसी चीज़
रिक्वेस्ट करी है जो जिसके लिए आप ऑथराइज़
हो ही नहीं। तो आपकी साइड से वो गलती है।
फॉरबिडन आपने कोई ऐसी रिसोर्स एक्सेस करी
है जिसको आप एक्सेस नहीं करने सक। आप उसके
लिए इंटेंडेडेंट नहीं थे। आप उसको एक्सेस
करने के लिए नहीं बने थे। कोई और एक्सेस
करने के लिए बना था। इसलिए आपको फॉरबिट कर
दिया गया है। 404 आपने कोई ऐसे रिसोर्स
एक्सेस करने की कोशिश की जो एक्चुअली
एग्ज़िस्ट ही नहीं करता है सर्वर के पास।
तो ये क्लाइंट के तरफ से एरर मैसेज होते
हैं। और पांचवा जो होता है वो होता है
सर्वर एरर रिस्पांससेस। यानी कि सर्वर के
साइड से क्या रिस्पॉन्ससेस आ रहे हैं वो
एरर के फॉर्म में वो होती है 500 से 599
तक 500 टू 599 तक। जैसे कि 500 सर्वर एरर
या आपने देखा होगा बहुत सारे सर्व्सर्स
कभी-कभी वेबसाइट्स काम नहीं करती हैं। आ
जाता है 5O
या 5 डॉट 5x यानी फाइव से जो भी एरर कोड्स
आपको मिल जाए समझिए सर्वर के साइड से
फौल्टी है। आपका कोई सिस्टम का फौल्ट नहीं
है। आपका कोई इंटरनेट का फौल्ट नहीं है।
आपके डिवाइस का फौ्ट नहीं है। आपका कोई
फौ्ट नहीं है। दैट्स द बेटर वे टू
अंडरस्टैंड दीज़ स्टेटस कोड्स। आई होप यू
अंडरस्टुड। सो प्लीज लेट मी नो इफ यू
एक्चुअली अंडरस्टैंड दिस एचटीटीपीएस
स्टेटस कोड्स। बताइए मुझे आपने एक्चुअली
इसको समझा सभी को समझ में आया एचटीटीपी
स्टेटस कोर्स तो मुझे फटाफट बताइए
हम
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[खांसने की आवाज़] समझ में आ गया सबको
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] ठीक है अब
एचसीडीपी के बाद हम बात बात करते हैं
एचटीटीपी एस के बारे में। एचटीटी के बारे
में बात कर ली। बट एचटीटीपीएस क्या होता
है भैया? तो एचटीटीपी प्लस इंक्रिप्शन इज
कॉल्ड एचटीपीएस। ये बहुत छोटा सा टॉपिक
है। देखो आज का जो आज का जो सेशन है वैसे
भी छोटी सेशन थी बट मैंने थोड़ा इसको
डिटेल कर दिया है क्योंकि आपको चीजें कुछ
इंक्लूड करके बताई है। इतनी ज्यादा आपको
हालांकि जाने की जरूरत नहीं है। बट स्टिल
मैंने घुसा दिया थोड़ा सा तो उसको
समझिएगा।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] आज की सेशन
आपकी 1 घंटे में भी हो सकती बट यहां थोड़ा
सा टाइम और लग जाएगा। तो एचटीटीp प्लस
इंक्रिप्शन जो होती है यानी कि एचटीटीp को
जब सिक्योर कर दो तो एचटीटीपीएस कहलाती
है। अब ये इंक्रिप्शन एसएसएल एंड टीएलएस
एसएसएल या टीएलएस के थ्रू होता है। एसएसएल
जो है एक पुरानी टेक्निक है जिसको कि अब
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
बेसिकली जिसका सक्सेसर आ चुका है टीएलएस।
एसएसएल जो है सिक्योर सॉकेट लेयर उसका एक
सक्सेसर आ चुका है टीएलएस ट्रांसपोर्ट
लेयर सिक्योरिटी मोस्टली जो है वेब आपकी
टीएलएस पे अब काम करती है और ये जो है
पोर्ट नंबर 443 पे काम करता है एचटीdटीp
80 पे काम करता था ये इसके साथ जो पोर्ट
एसोसिएटेड है वो 443 एसोसिएटेड है। अब
इसका एक लॉजिक समझा देता हूं फंडा
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] जब भी आप
ब्राउज़र में कोई वेबसाइट ओपन करते हो कोई
भी डोमेन ओपन करते हो जैसे google.com तो
ये https पे काम कर रही है। तो ये
google.com सिर्फ ओपन नहीं होती है। ये
कॉलन 443 के साथ ओपन होती है। याद रखिएगा।
यानी कि इसको मैंने ओपन किया। ये भी
Google.com ही ओपन कर रहा है। देख लीजिए
यहां पे। तो मैं Google.com जो ओपन करता
हूं ना तो [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] हर
डोमेन के साथ एक IP एसोसिएटेड होता है।
मतलब पोर्ट नंबर एसोसिएटेड होता है। तो
बेसिकली ये कहना है मेरा कि हर आईपी के
साथ एक पोर्ट एसोसिएटेड होता है। सो
बेसिकली यहां पे मैं अगर Google की आईपी
निकालूं।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
राइट? सो इफ आई एम गोइंग टू पिंग Google
फॉर IP सॉरी फॉर द IP वर्जन 4 अगर मैं
करूं तो यहां पे मुझे एक IP मिलती है
142250 193 एंड 14 2 अब इस IP को अगर मैं
यहां पे डालूं [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओपन करूं तो ये ओपन हो जाएगा google.com
ओपन हुआ देखा IP चेंज हो गई google.com
में अब इसी IP के साथ में अगर कॉलन 443 भी
लगा दूं और मैं फिर भी एंटर करूं तो फिर
भी हमारा यहां पे
आपकी प्रोसीड करूंगा। मैं google.com ही
ओपन होगा। वो सर्टिफिकेट इशू था उसको हटा
दीजिए। तो यहां पे कहने का मतलब है कि
Google.com
की जो आईपी है या कोई भी आईपी वो एक पोर्ट
के साथ जनरली एसोसिएटेड होती है जो कि
कॉलन के बाद दिलाया जाता है। ये एक
सिंटेक्स होता है। आईपी कॉलन पोर्ट इसी
फॉर्म में होता है। बट हमें पोर्ट्स जनरली
जो एचटीटीपी पोर्ट्स हैं या एचटीटीपीएस के
पोर्ट्स हैं वो जनरली दिखते नहीं है।
जनरली नहीं दिखते। लेकिन अगर यहां पे
एफटीपी का करना हो, एसएसएच का करना हो तो
आपको कॉलन 22, 23, 21 ये देना पड़ेगा। तब
जाके वो एक्चुअल वहां पे आप विजिट कर
पाएंगे। दैट्स द मेन थिंग। क्योंकि ये
एचटीटीp के पोर्ट्स हैं तो ये जनरली इसको
बाय डिफॉल्ट क्या हाइड कर दिया गया कि अरे
कौन बार-बार 80 443 डालेगा? ये तो सभी लोग
एचटीटीपी ही यूज़ कर रहे हैं। वेबसाइट्स ही
उससे ओपन हो रही है। दैट्स व्हाई जस्ट
लेट्स रिमूव इट एंड लेट्स नॉट सी इट हियर
एंड जस्ट बैकग्राउंड में काम करने दो। बट
बाकी पोर्ट्स के लिए यहां पे एंटर करना
पड़ जाता है। तो आईपी कॉलन पोर्ट याद
रखिएगा इस कांसेप्ट को गाइस
समझ [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] में आ गया
होगा इतना। चलिए
चलिए सो पोर्ट 443 पे काम करता है। ये
आपको सीआईए प्रोवाइड करता है एचटीटीपीएस
कॉन्फिडेंशियलिटी इंटीग्रिटी एंड
अवेलेबिलिटी या ऑथेंटिकेशन जो भी कहें आप
तो सीआईए इसको प्रोवाइड करता है
एचटीटीपीएस क्योंकि सिक्योर है। सिक्योर
एचटीडीटीपी को हम एचटीडीपीएस कहते हैं।
एचटीटीपीएस क्यों मैटर करता है भैया?
क्योंकि अगर एसटीपीएस ना हो तो एमआईटीएम
जैसे अटैक्स हो सकते हैं। क्रेडेंशियल्स
जो है उसको स्निफ किए जा सकते हैं। और
डेटा जो है वो रीड की जा सकती है प्लेन
टेक्स्ट में। दैट्स द मेन इशू।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] अब आते हैं
डीएनएस के ऊपर। ये दो टॉपिक ही सबसे बड़े
टॉपिक थे आज के सेशन में क्योंकि मेन
इंपॉर्टेंट टॉपिक थे। बाकी तो छोटे-छोटे
प्रोटोकॉल्स हैं जो मैं आपको डील करूंगा।
अभी यहां पे बताऊंगा।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] अब डीएनएस पे
आते हैं। देखो ये डीएनएस हमारा कहां से आ
रहा है? कब से पीछा नहीं छोड़ रहा? यहां
से। देखो देखो प्रोटोकॉल्स की जब मैंने
बात करी थी तो मैंने बताया था डीएनएस होता
है जो कि डोमेन टू IPपी एड्रेस कन्वर्जन
का काम करता है। जब [खांसने की आवाज़]
मैंने [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
यहां पे
ये जो डिस्कस करी थी तो इसमें भी डीएनएस
सर्वर हमारा बीच में आया था जो कि
रिक्वेस्ट जब जा रही है तो डीएनएस सर्वर
रेल्व कर रहा है डोमेन को आईपी में वही
डीएनएस [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] हम यहां
पे समझने वाले हैं। इसको ध्यान से समझिएगा
डीएनएस को। अ डोमेन नेम सिस्टम इज़ द फोन
बुक ऑफ द इंटरनेट। जैसे आपके फोन में फोन
बुक होता है ना कांटेक्ट लिस्ट होता है तो
आप क्या करते हैं? आपको क्या सबके नंबर
याद होते हैं? नाम याद होते हैं ना?
ह्यूमन माइंड का एक ह्यूमन एक माइंड जो है
ना वो इस तरीके की बनी होती है कि
अल्फाबेटिकल थिंग्स उसको बहुत ईजीली याद
होती है लॉन्ग टर्म के लिए। बट न्यूमेरिकल
चीजों को वो बहुत ईज़ली एक तो याद नहीं कर
सकता। और लॉन्ग टर्म के लिए उसको याद नहीं
होता। अंटिल अनलेस कि वह बहुत बार रिपीट
याद करता हो या रिपीटेड चीज़ हो या बहुत
कॉमन चीज़ हो। राइट? तो आप में से कई लोगों
को आपके
10 दोस्तों के भी नाम याद ना नंबर याद
होंगे। नहीं होते हैं। कई लोगों को याद
नहीं होते। आज के टाइम में तो और नहीं
होते। पहले तो होते भी थे बट आज के टाइम
में बिल्कुल नहीं होते। बट 10 दोस्तों के
नाम जरूर याद होते हैं क्योंकि माइंड ऐसे
ही प्रोसेस करता है आपका। अल्फाबेट्स को
ईजीली एंड आराम से समझता है। लॉन्ग टर्म
के लिए याद रखता है। तो
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
डीएनए जो है आपका फोन बुक है इंटरनेट का।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ह्यूमन एक्सेस इनफेशन ऑनलाइन थ्रू डोमेन
नेम्स लाइक ny टाइम्स या espn.com या
youtube.com google.com ह्यूमंस के आप एज
अ ह्यूमन आप डोमेन नेम के थ्रू चीजों को
एक्सेस करते हो। इंटरनेट पे जो रिसोर्सेज
है या इनेशन है google.com yahoo.com,
youtube.com, Twitter.com, X.com,
व्हाटएवर
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़][गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
वेब ब्राउज़र्स इंटैक्ट थ्रू इंटरनेट
प्रोटोकॉल एड्रेसेस। वेब एड्रेस जो है वो
IP एड्रेसेस के थ्रू इंटैक्ट करते हैं।
उनको IPपी एड्रेसेस का पता है। डीएनएस
ट्रांसलेट्स डोमेन नेम टू IP एड्रेसेस सो
ब्राउज़र कैन लोड इंटरनेट रिसोर्सेज।
डीएनएस का काम है उन डोमेन नेम को
ट्रांसलेट कर देना IPपी एड्रेस में या मैप
कर देना IPपी एड्रेसेस पे। यानी जिस IPपी
एड्रेस से वो बिलोंग करते हैं उस पे मैप
कर देना और वो आईपी बता देना। फिर वो जो
ब्राउज़र है आपका क्लाइंट है वो कनेक्ट कर
लेगा उस आईपी से उस सर्वर के। बस डीएनएस
का काम इतना ही होता है। जैसे कि Google
को उसके IP पे मैप कर देना। जैसे Google
की जो भी IP होगी वो उस पे मैप कर देना।
डोमेन नेम सिस्टम यानी डीएनएस जो है वो
पोर्ट नंबर 53 पे ऑपरेट करता है। इसका भी
एक पोर्ट है। मैंने बताया था ना हर
प्रोटोकॉल का हर सर्विस का। आप डीएनएस को
प्रोटोकॉल बोलिए या एज अ सर्विस बोलिए। हर
प्रोटोकॉल का हर सर्विस का एक पोर्ट होता
है। फिक्स पोर्ट नंबर होता है। 53 इसका
पोर्ट नंबर है। और
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] ये मोस्टली
यूडीपी यूज करता है। ये एक यूडीपी
प्रोटोकॉल माना जाता है। तो ये यूडीपी
प्रोटोकॉल मोस्टली जो है इसको यूज़ करता
है। अब डीएनएस का जो रेोल्यूशन होता है।
अब देखो मैं आपको इसके
थ्रू पूरा बताऊंगा। सारा चीज
समझाऊंगा। बट [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
उसके पहले [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
इसको देखते हैं। डीएनएस का रेोल्यूशन होता
है। अब डीएनएस ना जैसे आईपी
लेकर खोज कर आता है। उसके कुछ प्रोसेस
होते हैं। ऐसे ही नहीं आईपी लेकर खोज के
ला देता है। ऐसे ही नहीं डोमेन का आईपी ला
के देता है। उसके प्रोसेस होते हैं। पहले
ब्राउज़र कैश में चेक करता है आईपी। देन
ओएस कैश में चेक करता है। देन आपकी
रिजॉल्वर जो आईएसपी होती है उसके लिए जा
उसके पास जाता है कि भैया है क्या आपके
पास इसकी आईपी? देन रूट सर्वर के पास जाता
है जो रूट मेन रूट सर्वर होते हैं। देन
टीएलडी सर्वर टॉप लेवल डोमेन जो सर्वर्स
होते हैं उसके पास जाता है। एंड लास्ट में
वो ऑथरेटिव सर्वर के पास जाता है जो कि
आपकी होस्टिंग कंपनी मान के चल लो वो होती
है। तो उनके पास तो आईपी होती ही होती है
क्योंकि वही आईपी आपको असाइन करते हैं। तो
ऑब्वियस सी बात है आईपी उनके पास होती है।
तो ये लास्ट में ब्रह्मास्त्र है।
ऑथोरेटिव नेम सर्वर अगर इन सबके पास नहीं
मिलती है तो लास्ट के पास जाके वो आईपी
लेकर आ जाता है। आईपी तो लाना ही है। उसका
वो काम है। जिससे पीछे वो बेचारा हट भी
नहीं सकता है। अब देखिए
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] ये काम कैसे
करता है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] अब जो आपका
ब्राउज़र है उसके पास Facebook.com से
कनेक्ट होने का रिक्वेस्ट आया आपके साइट
से। अब उसको पता नहीं है Facebook क्या है
तो वो Facebook की आईपी खोजेगा। आईपी
खोजने के लिए वो सबसे पहले रूट डीएनएस
सर्वर के पास जाएगा। अब रूट डीएनएस सर्वर
के पास अगर मिल गई देखो अगर मिल गई तो ठीक
है। नहीं मिली तो अब वह फिर कहां जाएगा?
टॉप लेवल डोमेन जो होते हैं टीएलडी
सर्वर्स उनके पास जाएगा। टॉप लेवल डोमेन
कौन से होते हैं? जैसे कि.com.net.org
ये सब होते हैं जो और फिर ऑथोरेटिव
नेम सर्वर ऑथरेटिव सर्वर के पास जाते हैं
जो आपकी होस्टिंग जहां पे आपकी वेबसाइट
होस्ट हो रही होती है। जहां पे आपने सब
कुछ होस्ट करके रखा है। इसको और अच्छे से
समझने के लिए मैंने एक और इमेज रखा है।
इसमें मैं आपको ज्यादा अच्छे से समझाऊंगा
और आपको ज्यादा अच्छे से समझ में आएगा। जब
डीएनएस की क्वेरी होती है, डीएनएस जब उसको
आईपी खोजनी होती है, तो उसका एक प्रोसेस
होता है। तो सबसे पहले मान लो यह
रिक्वेस्टिंग होस्ट है। यह आप हो और यह
आपका लोकल डीएनएस सर्वर है जो आपके सिस्टम
पे सेटअप है। मान लो
ये आपका [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] लोकल
डीएनएस सर्वर है। आप में से पता है आप
लोगों को? लोकल डीएनएस आपके सिस्टम में
डीएनएस सर्वर को डीएनएस के सर्वर को एंड
डीएनएस आईपी को मैनुअली कहां पे कॉन्फ़िगर
करते हैं? हाउ मेनी ऑफ यू नो एंड हाउ मेनी
ऑफ यू डोंट नो? [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
बोल लीजिए यू इफ यू नो यस इफ यू नो इफ यू
डोंट नो नो डीएनएस को क्फ़िगर जो करते हैं।
मान लो आप अपने करंट अ मान लो अभी आपका
इंटरनेट आप यूज़ कर रहे हो वाईफाई यूज़ कर
रहे हो। उसमें आपको डीएनएस चेंज करना है।
ऑटोमेटिक डीएनएस नहीं रखनी है। कुछ एक
फिक्स डीएनएस आईपी यूज़ करनी है। तो आप
कैसे करोगे? आपको पता है? कई लोगों को
कई लोगों को नहीं पता है।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] देखो
अभी जैसे ही मैं कंट्रोल पैनल ओपन करूंगा
तो यहां पे मैं नेटवर्क एंड शेयरिंग सेंटर
में चलता हूं यहां पे मेरा ये वाई-फाई है
जिससे मैं कनेक्टेड हूं। अब मैं इस पे अगर
ओपन करता हूं तो यहां पे प्रॉपर्टीज का
ऑप्शन मिलेगा। मैं इस पे चलता हूं। इसमें
आओगे नीचे में नीचे की तरफ यहां पे
प्रॉपर्टीज के ऊपर में तो यहां पे आईपीबी
वर्जन फोर ऑप्शन मिलेगा। इस पे डबल क्लिक
करोगे तो आपको [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
यहां पे इसकी कॉन्फ़िगरेशन ओपन होगी।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] अब यहां पे
आपको दो कॉन्फ़िगरेशन मिलेंगी। देखो एक
होता है ऑब्टेन IPपी एड्रेस ऑटोमेटिकली।
तो यही हमेशा सेलेक्ट होता है एंड ऑब्टेन
डीएनएस सर्वर एड्रेस ऑटोमेटिकली। ये भी
बाय डिफॉल्ट होता है। यानी कि इसका मतलब
है कि यहां पे एक प्रोटोकॉल है डीएचसीपी।
ठीक है? एक प्रोटोकॉल होता है डीएसीपी
जिसका काम होता है आईपी पूल से आईपीस को
डिस्ट्रीब्यूट करना आपके डिवाइसेस में।
यानी कि एक नेटवर्क के अंदर में मल्टीपल
डिवाइस कनेक्ट होता है एक वाई-फाई से। तो
सबको एक IP चाहिए। तो आईपी जो
डिस्ट्रीब्यूट करता है वो डीएसीपी करता
है। तो अभी डीएसीपी काम करेगा जब यह
कनेक्ट ये सिलेक्टेड होंगे और यहां पे
डीएनएस सर्वर जो है वो बाय डिफ़ॉल्ट आपकी
आईएसपी आपको प्रोवाइड कर रही है जो डीएनएस
सर्वर आईएसपी के साइट से वही यहां पे यूज़
हो रही है। यानी आपकी डेटा आईएसपी के
सर्वर से होते हुए आईएसपी के थ्रू होते
हुए जा रही है और आपकी डेटा आईएसपी रीड कर
सकता है। मतलब आपकी डेटा का समझ सकते हो
ना थोड़ा बहुत रहता है कंट्रोल। ठीक है? अब
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
अगर आपको कोई और डीएनएस सर्वर यूज़ करनी
है। जैसे कि कोई पब्लिक डीएनएस यूज़ करनी
है। Google की कोई डीएनएस यूज़ करनी है।
जैसे उसका एड्रेस 8.8.8.8844
ऐसे कुछ एड्रेसेस होते हैं। IPपी एड्रेस
डीएनएस भी एक IP एड्रेस के थ्रू ही आप
यहां पे डिनोट करोगे। या फिर आपको कोई एक
क्लाउड फेयर की पब्लिक आईपी जैसे 11.1.1.1
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
यूज़ करना है। तो आपको यहां पे यूज़ द
फॉलोइंग डीएनएस सर्वर करना पड़ेगा। एंड
यहां पे प्रेफर्ड डीएनएस सर्वर और एक
अल्टरनेटिव डीएनएस मान लो कि प्रेफर्ड
डीएनएस सर्वर आपका काम ना कर रहा हो तो
अल्टरनेटिव डीएनएस सर्वर वहां पे यूज़ हो
जाएंगी। तो मैं अगर Google की यूज़ कर लूं
कि 8.8.8 एंड अल्टरनेट में 8.8.4.4
ये [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] डाल के ओके
कर सकते हैं। फिर आपका जो क्वेरी जाएगा
आपका जो भी इंफॉर्मेशनेशन पास होगा वो
आपके आईएसपी के डीएनएस के थ्रू हो के ना
जाके मतलब आईएसपी के ना इन सर्वर्स के
थ्रू जाएगा जो कि Google की ओपन डीएनएस है
या यू कैन से पब्लिक डीएनएस है। तो यहां
पे थोड़ी कुछ-कुछ लोग सिक्योरिटी के लिए
यूज़ करते हैं। अह डिफरेंट काइंड ऑफ़ थिंग्स
कि आईएसपी के थ्रू डिटेल्स ना जाएं। इसके
लिए यूज करते हैं। बहुत सारे लोग यूज़ करते
हैं बेसिकली। बट मैं आपको रिकमेंड करूंगा
कि आप ऐसे मैनुअल कॉन्फ़िगरेशन नहीं
करेंगे। इट्स नॉट गुड इनफ। क्योंकि कई लोग
जब आप मैनुअल डीएनएस सर्वर करेंगे ना तो
आपका कई बार इंटरनेट काम करना बंद कर
देगा। तो मैं आपसे रिक्वेस्ट करूंगा अगर
आपको प्रॉपर नॉलेज नहीं है तो आप जो
डिफ़ॉल्ट ऑप्शन डीएनएस सर्वर ऑटोमेटिकली और
आईपी एड्रेस ऑटोमेटिकली। आप IPपी एड्रेस
को भी मैनुअल सेलेक्ट करके यहां पे खुद का
IP डिफाइन कर सकते हैं IP पूल का। बट ये
मत कीजिएगा। अगर आपको नॉलेज ज्यादा नहीं
है IP एंड इन सब चीजों का तो प्लीज मत
कीजिएगा। वैसे हम IPपी एड्रेसिंग वगैरह की
क्लास करेंगे तो उसमें मैं आपको बताऊंगा
भी। अभी आप इसको जो नॉर्मल पहले था वही
रखिएगा। एंड अगर आपको नॉलेज है थोड़ी बहुत
तो आप यहां पे ये यूज़ कर सकते हैं। बट
इसका एक ग्राफिकल फॉर्मेट है। अगर आपको
डीएनएस दूसरा यूज़ करना ही है तो दिस इज़ अ
वेरी वेरी इंटरेस्टिंग थिंग दैट आई वांट
टू टेल यू गाइस। वो है क्लाउड फ्लेयर का
वॉर।
आप [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] इसको यूज कर
सकते हैं। क्लाउड फ्लेयर वन क्लाइंट
स्टेबल रिलीज आप यहां पे आपको मिल जाएगा।
तो ये बेसिकली
स्टेबल क्लाउड फेयर वन क्लाइंट एक होता है
जिसको कि फॉर्मली वर्प कहा जाता था।
डब्ल्यू एआरपी। ठीक है? वॉर्प कहा जाता
था। ये एक पब्लिक डीएनएस पे काम करने वाली
यूटिलिटी है जो बेसिकली आपके डीएनएस को
चेंज कर देती है। मैं यहां पे अगर देखता
हूं वॉर्प है कि नहीं मेरे पास अभी अभी
शायद नहीं होगी। किसी भी Windows, Linux,
Mac सबके लिए डाउनलोड आप कर सकते हैं। एंड
यू कैन यूज़ इट। बस सिंपली इंस्टॉल कर
लीजिएगा। जैसे Windows के लिए यहां पे
आपको डाउनलोड लेज़स्ट वर्जन आपको मिल
जाएगा। एंड इंस्टॉल करके ओपन कीजिएगा। देन
यहां पे जैसे ही वहां पे ऑप्शन यहां पे
ऊपर में आपके टास्क बार में आ जाएगा।
कनेक्ट करने का ऑप्शन आ जाएगा आपको। एंड
आप कनेक्ट करेंगे। देन व्हाट विल हैपन?
यह डिस्कनेक्टेड। अच्छा डिस्कनेक्ट करना।
व्हाट विल हैपन? कि ये एक पब्लिक क्लाउड
फेयर डीएनएस से आपको कनेक्ट कर देगा और
आपकी ऑटोमेटिकली जो आपका जो डिफॉल्ट
डीएनएस है वो यूज़ नहीं होगा या पब्लिक
डीएनएस जो है यूज़ होने लगेगी। तो अगर आप
चाहें तो उस तरीके से इसको यूज़ कर सकते
हैं। राइट? वॉर्ब को या क्लाउड फेयर वन को
आप यूज़ कर सकते हैं पब्लिक डीएनएस की तरह।
ठीक है? रादर दैन द योर आईएसपी डीएनएस।
क्योंकि आपकी जो डेटा है वो डीएनएस के
थ्रू ही हो के जाती है। डीएनएस के थ्रू हो
के जानी जानी है। तो डीएनएस अगर आपका
आईएसपी है तो आईएसपी के पास आपकी डेटा जा
रही है। एंड अगर कोई और डीएनएस है तो उसके
थ्रू भी आपकी डाटा जा रही है। तो एक
रिकमेंडेशन आपको दूंगा मैं आपको करूंगा
मैं आपको रिकमेंड कि कभी भी डीएनएस जब आप
यूज़ करें पब्लिक डीएनएस या कोई और डीएनएस
तो कोई सेंसिटिव चीज शेयर मत कीजिए उस पे।
दैट्स नॉट रिकमेंडेड। राइट? चलिए
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
अब समझते हैं यहां पे।
ओके। अब मान लो एक आप अरे यार क्या हो
गया?
हम
अब यह रिक्वेस्टिंग होस्ट हैं आप। आप
रिक्वेस्ट कर रहे हैं। सबसे पहले आपकी
रिक्वेस्ट लोकल डीएनएस सर्वर के पास
जाएगी। जो आपकी डीएनएस सर्वर आपकी सेटअप
है उसके पास जाएगी। जैसे मान लो ये आईएसपी
के पास जाएगी। अब ये दो तरीके से ये
डीएनएस की हायरर्की काम करती है। एक
इटरेटिव क्वरी होती के थ्रू होती है और एक
होता है रिकर्सिव क्वरी। इटरेटिव क्वरी
में एक आपका लोकल डीएनएस सर्वर जो है ना
यही सब जगह जाएगा और आईपी खोज कर लाएगा और
रिकर्सिव में क्या होता है कि एक लोकल
डीएनएस सर्वर रूट डीएनएस सर्वर के पास
जाता है रूट जो है नेक्स्ट के पास जाता है
वो अगले के पास जाता है एंड उस तरीके से
फिर वो रिसोंड करके वापस आता है। जैसे
क्लाइंट सर्वर के बीच बात होती है।
क्लाइंट सर्वर को रिक्वेस्ट करता है।
सर्वर रिसोंड करता है। उसी तरीके से ये
रिकर्सिव होती है। बट यहां पे इटरेटिव
क्वरी में क्या होता है कि एक लोकल डीएनएस
सर्वर जो आपका है वहीं सब जगह जाता है।
बाकी जो डीएनएस हायरार्की में बाकी जो
स्टेप्स हैं बाकी जो सर्वर्स हैं उनके पास
जाता है। तो यहां पे हम इटरेटिव क्वरी की
बात कर रहे हैं। तो आपने एक रिक्वेस्ट करी
एक facebook.com या google.com डोमेन लोकल
डीएनएस सर्वर के पास जा। अब उसका काम है
उस Facebook या google.com के IP को खोज
कर लाके देना। अब वो सबसे पहले अपने इस
हरार्की में जाएगा रूट डीएनएस सर्वर के
पास। अब रूट डीएनए सर्वर के पास अगर उसको
आईपी मिल जाती है तो रूट डीएनए सर्वर
रिसोंड कर देंगे लोकल डीएनएस सर्वर को और
लोकल डीएनएस सर्वर हमारे रिक्वेस्टिंग
होस्ट को वो रिसोंड कर देंगे बट ठीक है
अगर मान लो बाय चांस नहीं मिलती है तो उस
केस में क्या होगा हमारे उस केस में क्या
होगा कि ये टीएलडी डीएनए सर्वर के पास
जाएगा टीएलडी डीएनए सर्वर के पास अगर होगी
तो रिसोंड कर देगा एंड मामला खत्म बट अगर
नहीं हुआ तो फिर यह ऑथॉरिटी डीएनए सर्वर
के पास जो उसका मेन जो ब्रह्मास्त्र
डीएनएस सर्वर जो कि आपकी होस्टिंग कंपनी
होती है जहां पे आपने होस्टिंग ले रखी है
डोमेन वगैरह आपने होस्ट कर रखा है वहां पे
जाता है और फिर वहां से आईपी लेकर आता है
एंड फिर मतलब सारा काम आपका लोकल डीएनएस
सर्वर एक-एक घर-घर जा के आपकी आईपी खोज कर
लाता है यह हो गया इटरेटिव रिकर्सिव में
वो घर-घर नहीं जाता है वो क्या करता है एक
बार रिक्वेस्ट आई यह रूट डीएनएस सर्वर के
पास गया और रूट डीएनए सर्वर को बोलता है
भाई अब तुम्हारी मर् तुम्हारी वह
रिस्पोंसिबिलिटी है तुम मुझे आईपी खोज के
लाओ अब रूट डीएनएस बोला अच्छा मुझे भी काम
करना पड़ेगा। इटरेटिव वाले में तो तुम ही
सबके पास जा रहे थे। अब मुझे दौड़ा रहे
हो। ठीक है। कोई बात नहीं मैं दौड़ जाता
हूं यार। क्या जाता है? अब रूट डीएनएस
सर्वर जाएगा। टीएल टीएलडी डीएनएस के पास।
अगर मिल गई तो ठीक है। यह रूट को वापस
करेगा। यह वापस लोकल को और लोकल यहां पे
मेन यूजर को। अगर टीएलडी को नहीं मिला
टीएलडी के पास नहीं मिला तो टीएलडी
बोलेगा। टीएलडी को कोई बोलेगा भाई तू आगे
जा। तो टीएलडी कहां जाएंगे भैया? हमारे
ऑथरिटिव डीएनएस सर्वर के पास। और इनके पास
तो होती ही है सारी चीजें। तो ये टीएलडी
को दे देंगे। टीएलडी हमारे रूट को दे
देंगे। रूट हमारे लोकल को दे देंगे। लोकल
हमारे रिक्वेस्टिंग होस्ट को दे देंगे।
एंड इस तरीके से IP फैच हो के आ जाती है
और फिर आपका ब्राउज़र कनेक्ट करता है सर्वर
से। सोचो ब्राउज़र सर्वर से कनेक्ट करता है
उसके बीच के ये पूरे स्टेप्स हैं।
प्रोसेससेस हैं डीएनएस का। ये हायरार्की
है। ओनली डीएनएस का हायरार्की है ये। कभी
थ्री वे हैंडशेक और वो सब चीज़ तो अलग चीज़
है। दैट इज़ अ डिफरेंट थिंग। सोचो ये सारे
प्रोसेस होते हैं।
समझ में आ रहा है आप लोगों को? समझ में आ
रहा है? एवरीवन गेटिंग?
एवरीवन अंडरस्टैंडिंग?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
सबका एक हायरार्की है यार डायरेक्ट कैसे
चला जाएगा? अच्छा आदित्य ने पूछा व्हाई
नॉट डायरेक्टली ऑस्ट्रेटिव नेम सर्वर?
सबका एक हायरार्की होता है। अच्छा एक बात
बताओ मुझे एक मैं आप ही से क्वेश्चन करता
हूं।
आदित्य आदित्य मैं डायरेक्ट आप ही से
क्वेश्चन करता हूं। आप Amazon से कुछ
खरीदते हो। मान लो Samsung की टीवी खरीद
ली। उसमें कोई गड़बड़ी आ जाती है। तो आप
मुझे बताओ कि आप कहां जाते हो? क्या आप
Samsung के एमडी को डायरेक्ट पकड़ते हो?
चल Samsung की टीवी खराब हो गई है। चल आजा
भाई रिपेयर रिपेयर करो। मेरे को जो भी
करना है करो। मैं तो कुछ नहीं जानता। या
आप Amazon पे कंप्लेन करते हो। Amazon
उसको एस्केलेट करता है। सेलर्स की
इनवॉल्वमेंट होती है। फिर डिस्प्यूट्स
होते हैं।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
सर्विस सेंटर होती है। सर्विस सेंटर से
लोग आते हैं। वह बनाते हैं। रिपेयर हो
जाती है तो ठीक है। नहीं होती है तो फिर
आगे एस्केलेट होती है। फिर आगे एस्केलेट
होगा तो हायर अथॉरिटी को जाता है। ऐसे
करके होती है ना? तो डायरेक्ट ऑथॉरिटी नेम
सब को क्यों जाएगा? यहां पे एक हायरार्की
बनी हुई है। उसके थ्रू ही जाएंगे। ऑब्वियस
सी बात है। है ना? ये भी तो थोड़ा सोचो।
क्या यार तुम भी
कॉमन सी चीज है [हंसी] कि तुम्हारी
हां [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] राइट? वही
चीज है। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] अब
आते हैं
सॉरी एज अ एसओसी इंडिकेटर डीएनएस के लिए
क्या हो सकता है? बहुत सारे डीएनएस
रिक्वेस्ट अगर आ रहे हैं तो खतरे की घंटी
है। सस्िशियस डोमेन अगर दिख रहे हैं एसओसी
एनालिस्ट को तो वो भी खतरे की घंटी है।
रैंडम सब डोमेनस आपको दिखने लग रहे हैं एज
अ एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट तो वो भी खतरे की घंटी
है। एंड डीएनएस टनलिंग का यूज़ किया जा
रहा है। एंड डीएनएस के थ्रू किसी तरह का
कुछ अप्रोच हो रहा है तो वो भी खतरे की
घंटी है। डीएनएस स्पूफिंग, डीएनएस टनलिंग
यानी डीएनएस डेटा का एक्सफिल्ट्रेशन,
डीजीए यानी कि डोमेन जनरेशन एल्गोरिदम ये
सब चीज़ अटैक्स अलग-अलग तरह के अटैक्स होते
हैं जो इसके थ्रू पॉसिबल हो सकते हैं। तो
एज अ एसोसिए एनालिस्ट L1 आपको बेसिकली
इंडिकेटर्स पे ध्यान देना होता है कि इस
तरह के कुछ इंडिकेटर्स या ऐसे बहुत सारे
और इंडिकेटर्स हो सकते हैं। अगर ऐसे कुछ
इंडिकेटर्स आपको मिलते हैं तो यहां पे
डीएनए से रिलेटेड अटैक्स हो सकते हैं।
राइट? दैट्स इट। तो ये जो थे हमारे भैया
आपके एचटीटीपी प्रोटोकॉल एंड देन डीएनएस
प्रोटोकॉल। अब आते हैं एफटीपी प्रोटोकॉल।
एफटीपी मैं यहां पे बहुत अब ये बहुत शॉर्ट
प्रोटोकॉल्स बहुत सिंपल मैंने आपको बताया
समझा रहा हूं मैं आपको। बहुत छोटी-छोटी
चीजें हैं। इसको समझ लीजिएगा थोड़ा सा।
थोड़ा सा एक्सप्लोर भी कर लीजिएगा कि भैया
क्लास के बाद एफटीपी प्रोटोकॉल क्या होती
है? थोड़ा देख लीजिएगा। ये एक फाइल
ट्रांसफर प्रोटोकॉल है। बस फाइल ट्रांसफर
के लिए यूज़ होती है। इसका एक पोर्ट नंबर
एसोसिएटेड है 21। प्लेन टेक्स्ट में इसमें
चीजें ट्रांसफर होती है। ये सिक्योर नहीं
होती है। इसमें एक्टिव मोड में और पैसिव
मोड में जो है आप फाइल ट्रांसफर कर सकते
हैं। यानी एक इंटरेक्टिव वे में एक नॉन
इंटरेक्टिव वे में। इसी का एक भाई है जो
सिक्योर भाई है। एस एफटीपी सिक्योर
एफटीपी। यह एसएसएच के ऊपर काम करता है
क्योंकि अब जो है प्रोटोकॉल एफटीपी
प्रोटोकॉल ऑलमोस्ट डेप्रिशिएट कर दी गई
है। मतलब कुछ खास यूज़ नहीं होती है। जनरली
ब्राउज़र्स भी इसको सपोर्ट नहीं अब करते
हैं। क्लाइंट सॉफ्टवेयर के थ्रू ही होता
है। बट स्टिल जो एसएफटीपी हो वो एसएसएच
पोर्ट के ऊपर रन करती है। बेसिकली सिक्योर
होती है ये और इंक्रिप्टेड होती है। ठीक
है?
एसोसिएट इंडिकेटर में क्या हो सकते हैं?
बहुत बड़े-बड़े फाइल ट्रांसफरर्स हो रहे
हैं। अगर अननोन अपलोड्स हो रहे हैं,
एनोनिमस लॉगिनस हो रहे हैं। इस तरीके की
चीजें हो रही हैं। तो भैया यहां पे कुछ
गड़बड़ है। एफटीएफ से रिलेटेड कुछ ना कुछ
इशू हो रहा है। तो इसी में अटैक्स अलग-अलग
तरह के क्रेडेंशियल स्निफिंग अटैक होते
हैं। डेटा एक्सफिल्ट्रेशन अटैक होते हैं।
ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक होते हैं। डिफरेंट काइंड
ऑफ़ अटैक्स आर देयर। राइट? तो ये एफटीपी के
रिलेटेड हो गया। अब आते हैं यहां पे
एसएमटीपी। सिंपल मेल मेल ट्रांसफर
प्रोटोकॉल या सिंपल मैसेज ट्रांसफर
प्रोटोकॉल कुछ भी आप बोल सकते हैं। तो
यहां पे सिंपल मेल ट्रांसफर प्रोटोकॉल जो
कि एक ईमेल सेंडिंग प्रोटोकॉल होता है
जिसके थ्रू आप ईमेल सेंड करते हैं। सो
बेसिकली यू सेंड ईमेल। पोर्ट नंबर कौन सा
होता है इसका? 25 होता है और एक 587 होता
है। 25 जो है एसएमटीपी का पोर्ट होता है।
587 सिक्योर सबमिशन के लिए पोर्ट यूज़ में
लिया जाता है। सो यहां पे हियर बेसिकली
थ्री टू पोर्ट्स आर बीइंग यूज़्ड एस
एसएमटीपी के लिए। तो यहां पे 25 जो है
एसएमटीपी का पोर्ट होता है। तो क्या होता
है? सेंडर जो है मेल सेंड करता है।
एसएमटीपी के थ्रू मेल सेंड होती है।
इंटरनेट के थ्रू यहां पे मेल सर्वर तक
जाती है और मेल सर्वर से जब रिसीवर को
पहुंचती है तो वो पॉप थ्री करके एक
प्रोटोकॉल होता है। उसके थ्रू रिसीव ये
होती है जो कि बेसिकली पॉप थ्री एक
प्रोटोकॉल बोल लो या सर्विस बोल लो उसके
थ्रू रिसीव होती है। इस तरीके से मेल
सेंडिंग काम करती है। सेंडर ने एसएमटी का
भी एसएमटीपी का यूज़ किया। इंटरनेट के
थ्रू एसएमटीपी के थ्रू मतलब मेल सर्वर तक
पहुंचाया। मेल सर्वर से रिस्पांस आता है
रिसीवर को पॉप थ्री करके एक प्रोटोकॉल है
उसके थ्रू।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
अगेन वही एसओसी इंडिकेटर में बल्क ईमेल
सेंडिंग अगर हो रही है। बहुत सारी ईमेल
सेंड हो रहे हैं। अननोन डोमेनस से ईमेल
सेंड हो रही है। आपको पता ही नहीं है कौन
से डोमेन है। उससे सेंड हो रही है। ईमेल
स्पूफिंग हो रही है। एक ईमेल से ही बहुत
सारे ईमेल्स की फ्लडिंग हो गई है। बहुत
सारी ईमेल्स आपको भेजी जा रही है। तो इसको
ईमेल स्पूफिंग के थ्रू हो सकती है या किसी
ऑथेंटिक टाइप लिखने वाले ईमेल से आपको मेल
आ रहे हैं जो कि एक्चुअली उस बंदे ने नहीं
भेजा। उस ऑर्गेनाइजेशन ने नहीं भेजा। तो
ईमेल स्पोफिंग [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
का पार्ट होता है। तो ये एसोसिए इंडिकेटर
में आपके आ जाएंगे। एंड अटैक्स में आपके
फिशिंग अटैक्स, स्पैम कैंपेस, ईमेल
स्पोफिंग ये सारे अटैक्स में आपके आ जाते
हैं। अब वही जो मैंने एसएफटीपी बताया था
सिक्योर एफटीपी। तो वो एसएसएच के ऊपर काम
करती है। मैंने बताया था वही एसएसएच है
सिक्योर शेल। यह एक सिक्योर रिमोट एक्सेस
प्रोटोकॉल है या रिमोट लॉग इन प्रोटोकॉल
है जिसके थ्रू आप रिमोटली किसी सिस्टम में
एक्सेस करते हो या लॉगिन करते हो एंड
सिक्योरली करते हो। पोर्ट नंबर 22 पे ये
ऑपरेट करती है। सिंपल सा फंडा है पोर्ट 22
इज़ द एसएसएच पोर्ट। अब
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
यहां पे इंडिकेटर्स क्या हो सकते हैं?
मल्टीपल फेल्ड लॉगिनस। लॉग इन फ्रॉम
अनयजुअल आईपी रूट लॉगिन अटेम्प्ट्स। अगर
ऐसे कुछ हो रहे हैं तो इसका मतलब है
एसएसएच के ऊपर खतरा हो सकता है क्योंकि
फेल्ड लॉगिनस बहुत सारे हो रहे हैं। लॉग
इन अनयुअल आईपी से लॉग इन हो रहे हैं। रूट
के लिए कोई अटेम्प्ट कर रहा है लॉग इन
यानी एसएसएच के थ्रू मोस्टली रूट
अटेम्प्ट्स होते हैं। तो यहां पे अटैक्स
में अलग-अलग तरह के ब्रूट फ़ोर्स
क्रेडेंशियल थप्ट ऑथराइज एक्सेस देयर आर
मल्टीपल अटैक्स दैट
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] कुड हैपन थ्रू
एसएसएच। उसी तरीके से एक प्रोटोकॉल होता
है आरडीपी रिमोट डेस्कटॉप प्रोटोकॉल। अब
आरडीपी का आरडीपी प्रोटोकॉल आपके सिस्टम
में भी दिख जाएगा।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ये आपके Windows में भी होता है रिमोट
डेस्कटॉप कनेक्शन। यहां पे आप मेन
कंप्यूटर का आप जो भी आईपीओपी डालना है
डाल दीजिए। उसके बाद यूजरनेम पासवर्ड
पूछेगा एंड देन आप कनेक्ट कर सकते हैं उस
कंप्यूटर से आरडीपी के थ्रू। रिमोट
डेस्कटॉप प्रोटोकॉल के थ्रू। तो यही वो
आरडीपी है बेसिकली रिमोट कंट्रोल ऑफ
विंडोज सिस्टम या किसी भी तरीके की सिस्टम
को आप एक्सेस कर सकते हैं आरडीपी के थ्रू
रिमोट रिमोटली ग्राफिकली बेसिकली यू कैन
से तो पोर्ट नंबर 33 89 ये एक फिक्स पोर्ट
नंबर होता है इसका आरडीपी का एसओस
इंडिकेटर्स में क्या है लॉग इन ऐड ऑड
आवर्स ऑड आवर्स पे आपको लॉगिन मिलेगा
मल्टीपल लॉग इन अटेम्प्ट्स देखने को
मिलेंगे एक्सटर्नल आईपी लॉगिन होगी
एक्सटर्नल आईपी लॉगिन आपको हो सकती है तो
यहां पे आरडीपी ब्रूड फ़ोर्स हो सकता है,
लेटरल मूवमेंट हो सकती है, रैंसमयर एंट्री
पॉइंट हो सकता है। आरडीपी के थ्रू ये सारी
चीजें पॉसिबल है। ब्रूट फ़ोर्स हो सकती है।
लेटरल मूवमेंट वगैरह जो मैंने आपको ऑलरेडी
बताया रसमवेयर के बारे में बताया हुआ है।
तो मैं आपको ये चीजें इसलिए डिटेल में डील
नहीं कर रहा हूं क्योंकि मैंने आपको इन सब
के बारे में लिटिल बिट ऑफ़ हिंट ऑलरेडी या
एक अच्छी खासी सेशन के थ्रू आपको डिलीवर
कर चुका हूं। मैं ब्रूट फ़ोर्स के बारे में
बताया, लेटरल मूवमेंट के बारे में बताया
है, रसमवेयर के बारे में बताया, सब बताया
हुआ है। दैट्स व्हाई जस्ट ये थोड़ा सा
पॉइंट वाइज मैं आपके साथ यहां पे चल रहा
हूं। बट यह समझ लीजिए कि यह प्रोटोकॉल्स
के बारे में थोड़ी कॉमन प्रोटोकॉल्स हैं।
उनके बारे में जानिए। हालांकि देयर आर
मल्टीपल प्रोटोकॉल्स। तो आपका
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] एक टास्क यह भी
है कि आपको अलग-अलग प्रोटोकॉल्स के बारे
में जानना है एंड आपको देखना है कि कितने
प्रोटोकॉल्स होते हैं और क्या-क्या
एग्जैक्टली काम करते हैं, कैसे काम करते
हैं। ये आपका टास्क है। इसको थोड़ा
एक्सप्लोर आपको करना है। देन आते हैं
एसएमबी प्रोटोकॉल जिसको हम बोलते हैं
सर्वर मैसेज ब्लॉक। अब ये क्या काम करते
हैं? ये फाइल शेयरिंग होते हैं Windows
नेटवर्क के अंदर। फाइल शेयरिंग वाली जो
पार्ट है उसको हैंडल करते हैं Windows
नेटवर्क के अंदर में। ये 445 पोर्ट पे
बेसिकली ऑपरेट करते हैं। एसओसी की तरह
इंडिकेटर में क्या हो सकता है? एक्सेस टू
एडमिन शेयर्स फाइल मूवमेंट अक्रॉस
सिस्टम्स लेटरल मूवमेंट। मतलब कोई एडमिन
शेयर्स से अगर कोई शेयरर्ड फोल्डर
डायरेक्टरीज़ हैं जो आपने एज एन एडमिन शेयर
करा है तो उसको एक्सेस अगर कोई करने की
कोशिश कर रहा है या फाइल्स को मूव कर रहा
है एक सिस्टम से दूसरे सिस्टम के अंदर में
या लैटरल मूवमेंट हो रही है एक कंप्यूटर
से दूसरे कंप्यूटर में एक नेटवर्क के अंदर
में। तो ये सारी चीजें अगर हो रही है तो
समझिए एसएमबी के ऊपर अटैक पॉसिबल है।
राइट?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
आपके ही भरोसे हूं कॉलेज फालतू अरे क्या
बात है कोई बात नहीं यार अच्छी बात है आप
भरोसे रहिए एकदम बिल्कुल आपको चीजें बताई
जाएंगी बिल्कुल बेफिक्र रहिए सर ये तो है
कि हमें ही बहुत कुछ देखना है एंड रिसर्च
हमें ही अच्छे से करना है बिल्कुल आपको
रिसर्च करना ही है और देखना ही है बिना
रिसर्च किए किसी भी तरह की ट्रेनिंग एंड
कोर्स कंप्लीट नहीं हो सकती है। कोई भी
नहीं करा सकता। आपको कोई करा भी दे पूरी
ट्रेनिंग कोर्स फिर भी आपको रिसर्च करना
है। वो बेस्ट अप्रोच बेस्ट तरीका होता है।
उसके बिना देयर इज़ नथिंग। बस इतना ही मैं
बोलूंगा। तो रिसर्च वाली बात एंड
एक्सप्लोर वाली बात को मेरी थोड़ा
सिंसियरली और सीरियसली लीजिएगा और उसको
एक्चुअली कीजिएगा। अटैक्स में इटरनल ब्लू
एक्सप्लइट एक था इटरनल ब्लू वनेबिलिटी
बेसिकली थी। उस पे बेस्ड एसएमबी रिले अटैक
एंड लेटरल मूवमेंट। ये सारी चीजें अटैक
होती है एसएमबी को लेकर। अब यहां पे हम
आते हैं कंप्यूटर पोर्ट्स के बारे में। ये
तो आपने पढ़ लिया आपने प्रोटोकॉल्स क्या
होते हैं? अब पोर्ट्स के बारे में थोड़ा
समझते हैं कि भैया ये पोर्ट्स क्या होते
हैं? देखो अ पोर्ट इज अ वर्चुअल पॉइंट
वेयर नेटवर्क कनेक्शंस स्टार्ट एंड एंड।
पोर्ट क्या होता है? एक वर्चुअल पॉइंट
होता है कंप्यूटर नेटवर्क में। जहां से
कनेक्शंस स्टार्ट भी होते हैं और एंड भी
होते हैं। मतलब एक दरवाजा बोल सकते हो।
जैसे आपके घर के अंदर में आना है तो एक
दरवाजे के थ्रू कोई आएगा ना तो एक दरवाजा
पोर्ट होता है जिसके थ्रू कोई एंटर भी हो
सकता है बाहर भी निकल सकता है। पोर्ट्स आर
सॉफ्टवेयर बेस्ड एंड मैनेज्ड बाय अ
कंप्यूटरर्स ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम। यहां
सॉफ्टवेयर पोर्ट्स की बात हो रही है।
हार्डवेयर पोर्ट्स भी होते हैं। हार्डवेयर
पोर्ट्स का मतलब जैसे आपके लैपटॉप में USB
पोर्ट होता है जिसमें आप पेनड्राइव वगैरह
लगाते हो। टाइप सी पोर्ट हो गया। टाइप सी
डिवाइसेस लगाते हो या थंडरबोर्ड पोर्ट
टाइप सी का ही जो वर्ज़न है एक वह हो गया
आपका। HDMI पोर्ट RJ45 केबल लगाते हो।
इथरनेट पोर्ट वो पोर्ट हो गया। एसडी कार्ड
स्लॉट वो भी पोर्ट हो गया। तो ये
हार्डवेयर पोर्ट्स हो गए। बट यहां पे मैं
बात कर रहा हूं सॉफ्टवेयर पोर्ट्स जहां से
सर्विसेज घुसती हैं अंदर जिसके जिसके थ्रू
आप सर्विज को एक्सेस करते हैं। जैसे
एचटीटीp को एक्सेस करना है तो उसका एक
पोर्ट है। उसका एक दरवाजा है जिसका पोर्ट
नंबर 80 है। https को एक्सेस करना है तो
उसका एक दरवाजा है जिसका पोर्ट नंबर 443
है। फाइल ट्रांसफर प्रोटोकॉल एफटीp को तो
21 पोर्ट से एक्सेस कर सकते हो। तो ऐसे ये
चीजें काम करती हैं इन टर्म्स ऑफ़
सॉफ्टवेयर बेस्ड पोर्ट्स। ईच पोर्ट इज़
एसोसिएटेड विद अ स्पेसिफिक प्रोसेस और
सर्विसेस। यानी कि हर पोर्ट एक सर्विस या
प्रोसेस या एक प्रोटोकॉल से एसोसिएटेड
होती है जो मैंने पहले ही बताया हुआ है।
पोर्ट्स [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] अलाउ
कंप्यूटरटर्स टू ईज़ली डिफरेंशिएट बिटवीन
डिफरेंट काइंड्स ऑफ़ ट्रैफिक। ठीक है?
पोर्ट्स ही यह डिफरेंट टाइप्स ऑफ ट्रैफिक
के बीच का डिफरेंशिएट करते हैं। ईमेल्स गो
टू अ डिफरेंट पोर्ट देन वेब पेजेस फॉर
इंस्टेंस इवन दो बोथ रीच अ कंप्यूटर ओवर द
सेम इंटरनेट कनेक्शंस। क्योंकि पोर्ट
अलग-अलग होते हैं। इसीलिए ईमेल जो है आपकी
अलग चीज होती है। अलग तरीके से आपकी अलग
जगह पे आपकी आती है और वेब पेजेस आप अलग
तरीके से ओपन करते हो। अब ईमेल आपकी Gmail
वगैरह में लैंड करती है। वहां पे आपको
मिलती है। वेब पेज आप ब्राउज़र के थ्रू
एक्सेस करते हो क्योंकि पोर्ट्स अलग-अलग
हैं। दो अलग-अलग सर्विज चल रही हैं। दैट्स
व्हाई तो ये डिफरेंशिएट करते हैं। देयर आर
टोटल 65535
पोर्ट्स। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
देयर आर टोटल 65535
पोर्ट्स
बट इसमें सारे यूज़ में नहीं आते। ठीक है?
बट इसमें सारे यूज़ में हम नहीं लेते हैं।
मतलब कि यहां पे टोटल 65535
पोर्ट्स होते हैं अवेलेबल हमारे कंप्यूटर
के अंदर में। बट इसमें कुछ कॉमन पोर्ट्स
होते हैं जिनको हम वेल नोन पोर्ट्स बोलते
हैं। उन्हीं को हम यूज़ लेते हैं। हम उसके
बारे में भी जानेंगे। बट इतना याद रखिए
इतने पोर्ट्स होते हैं।
अब इस [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] कुछ की
पॉइंट्स को समझिए।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] ईच पोर्ट इज
नंबर्ड फ्रॉम जीरो टू 65535।
तो यू कैन अगर इंक्लूड जीरो तो 65536 हो
जाएंगे। बट 65535 पोर्ट्स ही आपको बोलने
हैं। एंड इज़ डिवाइडेड इंटू डिफरेंट
ग्रुप्स। ठीक है? एंड ये ग्रुप्स कौन से
होते हैं? एक आपका वेल नोन पोर्ट्स होता
है। एक आपका रजिस्टर्ड पोर्ट्स होते हैं।
आपको डायनेमिक या प्राइवेट पोर्ट्स होते
हैं। अब वेल नोन पोर्ट्स जो होते हैं वो
ज़ीरो से 1023 तक होते हैं। तो ये रिजर्व्ड
फॉर स्टैंडर्ड सर्विज। अब जो जितने भी
स्टैंडर्ड सर्विज एंड प्रोटोकॉल्स एंड जो
भी प्रोसेससेस होते हैं जैसे एचटीडीपी,
एसएमडीपी, डीएनएस, एचटीडीपी, एसएफटीपी,
एसएसएच ये सब वेल नोन पोर्ट्स के अंदर ही
आते हैं। 0 से 1023 तक ये सारे आ जाते
हैं। देन होते हैं रजिस्टर्ड पोर्ट्स।
सॉरी
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
रजिस्टर्ड पोर्ट जो होते हैं वो 1024 से
49151 तक होते हैं। यूज्ड बाय स्पेसिफिक
एप्लीकेशनेशंस लाइक डेटाबेसिस। अब ये जो
डेटाबसेस और कुछ अलग स्पेसिफिक
एप्लीकेशनेशंस होते हैं वो इन पोर्ट्स को
यूज़ करते हैं। जैसे माय सीक्वल मायक्यूएल
का 3306 आता है आपका एसक्यूएल सर्वर 1433
तो ऐसे स्पेसिफिक एप्लीकेशनेशंस इन
पोर्ट्स को यूज़ करती है। उसके बाद होते
हैं डायनेमिक या प्राइवेट पोर्ट्स जो
49152 से 65535 तक होते हैं। ये क्या होते
हैं? टेंपरेरी असाइन फॉर क्लाइंट
कनेक्शंस। लाइक व्हेन योर ब्राउज़र ओपन अ
पोर्ट टू कनेक्ट टू अ वेबसाइट।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
यह होते हैं टेंपरेरी असाइन होते हैं।
जैसे मान लो कि आपने कोई ब्राउज़र से किसी
पर्टिकुलर वेब एप्लीकेशन से कनेक्ट करना
चाहा तो उस समय किसी एप्लीकेशन से कनेक्ट
कर रहे हैं तो एक टेंपरेरी पोर्ट असाइन हो
जाएगा। वो होते हैं डायनेमिक या प्राइवेट
पोर्ट्स जो कि टेंपरेरी असाइन होते हैं।
सिंपल। अब देखो इसमें भी अब इंटरनल
पोर्ट्स भी होते हैं। एक्सटर्नल पोर्ट्स
एक होते हैं। तो इंटरनल पोर्ट्स यूज्ड
ओनली यूज्ड इनसाइड योर प्राइवेट नेटवर्क।
जैसे लन लोकल कम्युनिकेशन के लिए।
एक्सटर्नल पोर्ट्स आर ओपन टू द इंटरनेट।
राउटर्स मैप देम टू इंटरनल पोर्ट्स। सो
एक्सटर्नल यूज़र्स कैन एक्सेस सर्विसेस
सेफली। इंटरनल पोर्ट्स जो होते हैं वो
आपके लैंड के लिए होते हैं। लोकल एरिया
नेटवर्क हैं। जैसे एक घर है। एक घर में
जितने भी सिस्टम एक कंप्यूटरटर्स एक जितने
कंप्यूटरटर्स मोबाइल, फोन, टैब एक नेटवर्क
से जुड़े हैं उसमें जो पोर्ट्स यूज़ हो
रहे हैं वो इंटरनल पोर्ट्स हैं। और
एक्सटर्नल पोर्ट्स जो हैं वो इंटरनेट के
लिए ओपन होते हैं। जहां पे क्या होता है
कि एक राउटर होता है वो एक्सटर्नल पोर्ट
के थ्रू क्या करता है? मैप करता है आपके
इंटरनल पोर्ट पे। जैसे जिसको हम पोर्ट को
फॉरवर्ड करना बोलते हैं। पोर्ट
फॉरवर्डिंग। जैसे मान लो कि आपका ये आपने
यहां पे कोई स्पेसिफिक एसएसएस सर्विस
स्टार्ट की। अब आपने पर्टिकुलर पब्लिक
आईपी को मैप कर लिया आपके प्राइवेट आईपी
पे एसएसएस सर्विस को यूज़ करने के लिए। तो
आपको उसको प्राइवेट आईपी को बेसिकली आपको
मैप करना पड़ेगा उस सर्विस को। तो वो
मैपिंग एक्सटर्नल पोर्ट्स के थ्रू होती
है। फिलहाल इस कांसेप्ट को इतना समझना
आपके लिए इंपॉर्टेंट नहीं है। अगर आपको
आता है तो अच्छी बात है। अदरवाइज़ आप सिंपल
सा एक कांसेप्ट समझ लीजिएगा। पोर्ट
फॉरवर्डिंग क्या होती है? इसको थोड़ा
एक्सप्लोर कर लीजिएगा। अदरवाइज़ डज़ंट नीड
एक्चुअली एक्चुअली यू डोनेट इट। बस इसको
समझना है। वेल नोन पोर्ट, रजिस्टर पोर्ट,
डायनेमिक पोर्ट्स तीन टाइप के आपके
पोर्ट्स होते हैं। एंड ये रेंज होता है
पोर्ट का जो कि ज़ीरो से लेके 655 35 तक
होते हैं। एंड ये सब मैंने आपको यहां पे
क्लियर करा।
अब [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] यहां पे कुछ
कॉमन पोर्ट्स हैं जो कि आप वैसे तो मैंने
कुछ पोर्ट्स लिए हैं बट यहां पे आप
मल्टीपल और भी पोर्ट्स बहुत सारे होते हैं
जो कॉमनली यूज़ होते हैं। आप उनको देख
लीजिएगा थोड़े। कॉमन पोर्ट्स सर्च कीजिएगा
आपको मिल जाएगा। बस कॉमन पोर्ट्स थोड़ा सा
आप देख लीजिएगा। ये सब देखो मैं इन चीजों
पे ज्यादा फोकस इसलिए नहीं करता क्योंकि
ये मेमोराइज़ करने की चीज़ हैं। रटा या याद
करने की चीज़ हैं। एंड प्रैक्टिस के
साथ-साथ आपके दिमाग में भी बैठ जाएंगे। तो
जैसे कि मान लो पोर्ट नंबर 21 एफटीपी के
लिए होता है फाइल ट्रांसफर। पोर्ट नंबर 22
एसएसएच के लिए होता है सिक्योरि रिमोट
एक्सेस। 25 एसएमटीपी के लिए होता है ईमेल
सेंडिंग। 53 डीएनएस के लिए होता है डोमेन
रेोल्यूशन। 80 एचtपी के लिए होता है वेब
ट्रैफिक। 443 एचtडीपीएस होता है। यह भी
वेब ट्रैफिक होता है। बट सिक्योर वेब
ट्रैफिक। 3389 आरडीपी के लिए होता है
रिमोट डेस्कटॉप लॉग इन 445 एसएमबी होता है
फाइल शेयरिंग या रिमोट फाइल शेयरिंग
व्हाटएवर तो ये कुछ कॉमन पोर्ट्स हैं जो
आप देख सकते हैं एंड अगर रियल एसओसी लॉग
एग्जांपल की बात करें तो एसओसी रियल लॉग
आपको कुछ इस तरीके की लॉग देखने को मिलेगी
लॉग में आपको दिखेगा सोर्स आईपी
डेस्टिनेशन आईपी पोर्ट 3389 याद रहे आपको
3389 आपका आरडीपी पोर्ट है याद रखिएगा एंड
स्टेटस फेल्ड इसका मतलब है कि कोई आरडीपी
ब्रूट फ़ोर्स कर रहा है। आरडीपी के ऊपर
ट्राई मार रहा है। तो आपके दिमाग में
तुरंत आना चाहिए कि भ यहां पे आरडीपी
ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक लग रहा है। होने वाली
है। तो स्टेटस फेल तो हो चुका है। बट
ट्राई तो कोई मार रहा है। तो यू हैव टू
अंडरस्टैंड इट लाइक कि अ [हंसी]
आरडीबी वाली थिंकिंग। तो ये एज अ एसोसिएट
एनालिस्ट की थिंकिंग पावर आपके अंदर इस
तरीके की कुछ होनी चाहिए कि भैया एज अ
एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट मैं ये चीज़ सोच पा रहा
हूं। बस ये चीजें थी। तो ये आज की सेशन थी
जिसमें कि हमने कंप्यूटर पोर्ट्स एंड
कंप्यूटर एंड वेब प्रोटोकॉल्स के बारे में
समझा। इसको आप मोर स्पेसिफिकली वेब
प्रोटोकॉल्स लिख दीजिए या या नेटवर्क
प्रोटोकॉल्स लिख दीजिए या व्हाटएवर आपकी
मर्जी है वो बट यहां पे वेब या नेटवर्क
प्रोटोकॉल्स आप लिख सकते हैं। ठीक है? तो
ये जो थी पूरी की पूरी आज की सेशन जिसके
अंदर मैंने आपको वेब प्रोटोकॉल्स एंड आपको
बताया
पोर्ट्स के बारे में। ठीक है? कि कौन-कौन
से पोर्ट्स क्या-क्या चीज होते हैं। अब
आपके टास्क यह है कि वेब प्रोटोकॉल्स में
मैंने जैसे आपको कुछ लिमिटेड प्रोटोकॉल्स
के बारे में बताया। राइट? आपको मैंने यहां
पे जो बताया [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
लिमिटेड प्रोटोकॉल्स साथ में मैंने आपको
डीएनएस के बारे में बताया। तो थोड़ा
डीएनएस को एक्सप्लोर करना है। साथ में
आपको एचटीटीपी मेथड्स के बारे में बताया।
थोड़े से एचटीटीपी मेथड्स के बारे में
एक्सप्लोर कर लेना है। एचटीटीp स्टेटस
कोड्स के बारे में एक्सप्लोर कर लेना है।
ये टास्क हैं आपके। देन आपको डीएनएस के
बारे में तो करना ही है एक्सप्लोर। देन
कुछ कॉमन प्रोटोकॉल्स के बारे में पढ़
लीजिएगा। और भी कुछ आज के मैंने जो बताया
उसके अलावा अगर कुछ और भी आपको मिलते हैं
तो उनके बारे में हल्का-फुल्का नॉलेज ले
लीजिएगा कि ये क्या है क्या काम करते हैं।
दैट्स इट। इतना काफी हो जाएगा आपके लिए।
देन कंप्यूटर पोर्ट्स के बारे में थोड़ा
एक्सप्लोर कर लीजिएगा। एंड आपके जो
इंपॉर्टेंट एंड मेन कॉमन पोर्ट्स हैं ये
सारे पोर्ट्स के बारे में थोड़ा देख भी
लीजिएगा। इनके अलावा और कोई कॉमन पोर्ट्स
भी आपको मिलते हैं तो वो भी आप देख
लीजिएगा। दैट्स इट। ये आपका एक टास्क
रहेगा। बस दैट्स इट। ठीक है? चलिए आज का
सेशन वैसे तो सिर्फ 1 घंटे का सेशन होने
वाला था क्योंकि उतने 1 घंटे काफी थे आज
के सेशन के लिए बट स्टिल मैंने एक्सटेंड
किया क्योंकि मैंने कुछ चीजें ऐड कर दी थी
एक्स्ट्रा में आप लोगों के लिए ताकि आपको
थोड़ा और मजा आ जाए चीजों को समझने में।
बस दैट्स इट। ठीक है? तो चलिए बहुत अच्छा
लगा यहां पे। अब [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
या अब यहां पे मैं टॉप फैंस की लिस्ट में
आ जाता हूं। मैं जल्दी से टॉप फैंस की
लिस्ट ओपन कर देता हूं। एंड हियर इज़ द टॉप
फैंस लिस्ट वी हैव योर बॉय। वाओ यह नया
नाम लग रहा है। प्रदीप कुमार आदित्य निशा
मिस्टर रोबोट आशीष कुमार प्रशांत तनिजा
कश्मीर
कश्मीर अग्र कश्मीरा कुछ करके हैं।
जगतगुरु नईम पर्सनलाइज
बुंदेली वॉग्स रैंडम बॉय आकाश ललित
मोहनदास अमित खलीद
स्माइली भूत बांग भूत भूत भूत भी भूत भी आ
रहा है अपने सेशन में फर्स्ट स्कल इट्स मी
हाइपर राजगौर हर्षभ
जैक कंप्यूट अल्टीमेट गेमिंग आदि सिंह
सुजो शाह द एड्स एड एमएस पता नहीं क्या है
अमीला विष्णु चौधरी संदीप ठीक है मैं सबके
नाम अगेन में बहुत लंबा हो जाता है तो मैं
सबके नाम दिखा देता हूं बट एक्सट्रीमली
सॉरी अगर आपके नाम नहीं लिया है मैंने
क्योंकि काफी लंबा हो जाता है बहुत टाइम
जाता है इसमें तो ये सारे लोग जो हैं
हमारे टॉप फैंस के लिस्ट में हैं एंड थैंक
यू एवरीबॉडी एंड इवन टॉप फैंस के अलावा भी
सभी को धन्यवाद आप लोग इतना समय देते हैं
यहां पे आते हैं मैं आपसे एक रिक्वेस्ट
जरूर करूंगा कि जाते-जाते लाइक जरूर ठोकते
जाना अगर आपको मन करे तो ठोक देना कुछ लगे
कि कुछ सीखा है शेयर जरूर कर देना लोगों
के बीच ताकि कि लोगों को पता चले सीरीज के
बारे में अपने तक मत रखो नॉलेज। नॉलेज इज़
द थिंग दैट यू हैव टू शेयर एंड व
इट एक्चुअली अ एक्सपेंड व्हेन यू शेयर विद
समवन। तो आपका वो बेनिफिट ही होता है। तो
आप शेयर करते रहिएगा दोस्तों के बीच, सबके
बीच एंथूजियास्ट के बीच। एंड 200 कमेंट्स,
यूनिक कमेंट्स कीजिएगा। प्लीज डोंट प्ले
गेम्स विथ दैट कमेंट सिस्टम। उससे कोई
फायदा नहीं होगा। प्लीज। तो दैट्स इट। एंड
सब्सक्राइब कर लीजिएगा। नहीं किया हो तो
बेल आइकॉन प्रेस कर दीजिएगा। बस आज के लिए
बस इतना ही मजा आ जाएगा। अपकमिंग वीएपीडी
बैच की अनाउंसमेंट जल्दी आएगी। एंड थैंक
यू वेरी मच एंड सभी को गुड नाइट। टाटा
बाय-बाय। टेक केयर।
मिल